[Music]
andrew doyle is with me today
andrew is a british comedian playwright
journalist political satirist and author
who co-created the fictional character
jonathan pie
and the equally or perhaps even more
fictional character titanium mcgrath
he recently published his first book
free speech
why it matters which came out in 2021
but previously published two more as the
aforementioned
titanium mcgrath the first of those was
woke a guide to social justice
published in 2019 and the second was my
first little book of intersectional
activism
published in 2020 i haven't met andrew
before i'm
looking forward to talking with him
about free speech and about his
satire and about the intersection
between those two and and
whatever else comes up thank you very
much for coming on today i'm looking
forward to speaking with you
thanks so much for having me so shall we
start perhaps with the discussion of
your book i finished it yesterday
um i've become notorious i suppose for
my
particular take on free speech and so it
was a book that
interested me tell me why you wrote it
and
and and what you learned in all of those
things
well it's not the sort of book i ever
envisaged that i would have to write
um you know i think if you go back 10 15
years the idea that free speech which is
obviously what
the seed bed of all our liberties would
be something that we would
we would have to defend would have
probably seemed a little bit ridiculous
to me because i
basically took it for granted i thought
that everyone was on on that side
um but i fear that something has
happened uh
particularly over the past 10 years or
so and
it is connected i feel with the rise of
this social justice movement
what we might call critical social
justice or however we want to call it a
lot of people call it the woke movement
what however you want to label that
ideology which at it heart at its heart
has a real mistrust
of free speech and you hear it all the
time in the kind of phrases that the
activists use phrases like
words are violence or oh this kind of
language normalizes hate or legitimizes
hate or
all this kind of thing and there's a
real genuine mistrust of
the power of language to effectively
corrupt
the masses and what i wanted to do i
suppose
was try and marshal a defense for this
uh for this principle that i had always
always taken for granted
but at the same time attempt to grapple
with the concerns that people might have
because i i my worry with the culture
war as we call it is that
you have two sort of extreme poles uh
arguing against each other and most
people are caught in the middle i think
most people are broadly
for the idea of free speech but they
have a few reservations for instance
when it comes to
demagogues espousing hate or or hate
against a particular minority group or
something like that
or people are concerned about the ways
in which language can cause
harm and i don't think anyone would deny
that words can be hurtful so
most people i think are somewhere in
between and are open to persuasion i
think my
my point my principal argument in the
book is that uh
absolute freedom of speech is always
going to be better
and in fact by promoting free speech
you're doing something to help those
very
people that you are concerned about so
recently the scottish parliament passed
a hate crime law
that has its supporters and also its
detractors and
i'd be interested in your feeling about
that now you said i believe in this book
if if i remember the statistics
correctly that
there have been 120 000
incidents of police investigated
speech hate crime in britain in
how long since yeah that's been over the
last five years or so
it's it's it's worse than that the
statistic i quote is between 2014 and
there are 120 000 recorded incidents of
non-crime
they call them non-crime hate incidents
and this is something which is now
routine
in the uk i mean obviously i'm going to
be talking about the uk and
the us and canada is a very is a very
different kettle of fish i'm sure
and i'm sure a lot of the people who are
watching won't be familiar with with the
problems we have in the uk of course we
don't have
constitutional protection for free
speech we don't have a first amendment
uh we don't have anything like that so
we are particularly vulnerable
and at the moment unfortunately in the
uk uh the police who are
uh trained by the college of policing
who do issue very specific guidelines
about this
and anyone can check this because if you
go to the government's website on hate
crime
and hate speech they make very clear
what they're talking about what they say
is that there are five protected
characteristics and these fall into
race gender sexuality gender identity
and disability
uh i think i might misquote that but
there's one missing but anyway
there are five protected characteristics
and if
a victim and they do use the word victim
rather than complainant if a victim
perceives that any speech or crime was
motivated
by hatred towards any of those five
protected characteristics
then it qualifies as a hate crime if
it's criminal
if it's not criminal if it's just speech
or something like that it qualifies as a
non-crime hate incident
police will investigate that they will
record that and although non-crime
incidents don't lead to prosecution they
do go on a criminal reference check that
many people take
we call it a disclosure barring service
here so it can affect your employment
prospects
uh and is that without a trial that was
recorded without a trial
of course so you get a quasi-criminal
record
you get something flagged up when you
particularly if you're applying for a
teaching job say something like that
where you're working with children it's
very important and you get this thing
flagged up
so it does have serious ramifications
but even beyond that
we have hate speech laws which are
encoded into
the public order act which is one
example but the other the main example
is the electronic communications act
2003.
in this country and i do quote the
statistic in the book as well
we have roughly uh 3 000 people arrested
a year um for um offensive things that
they have said
online that's that's so in other words
nine people a day roughly the police
in the uk are arresting and that people
in the uk will be familiar with this
because if you see the twitter accounts
of various police forces various police
departments across the country
they often put things out like you know
make sure you don't say anything
offensive or thoughtless online or we
will be knocking on your door they say
these very kind of
frightening things there was a uh a
recent police um display
outside a supermarket um in the uk it
went viral this image
it was them next to a big digital
billboard and the slogan on the
billboard was
being offensive is an offense and this
was flanked by
police officers who were socially
distant but they were there in their
masks which made it seem
slightly more sinister um they got in a
lot of trouble for that because people
were saying well
being offensive surely isn't a crime um
but actually the problem with that is
that the police
clearly thought it was a crime and they
you know they were acting on that basis
they'd obviously hadn't just concocted
this billboard out of nothing they'd
really considered
what it should say and more to the point
actually they were right
in this country you can uh go to prison
for jokes for offensive remarks um and
people have gone to prison have been
arrested
uh routinely for for causing offense and
of course
the notion of offence is incredibly
subjective
in fact in fact the the legal
stipulation in the communications act
is that you will have broken the law if
the judge and jury deem
that you have communicated material that
is quote unquote grossly offensive
well i don't know how you define that i
i i wouldn't also who defines it is the
real question as far as i'm concerned i
mean
i've looked into this legislation to
some degree and
one of the things that struck me about
it was that
it seems to be purposefully left up to
the hypothetical victim to define
offense which has become a subjective
reality if
if and and you can understand why that
might be to some degree because
how would you define hate and how would
you define offense without especially
the latter without making recourse to
someone's subjective experience
but then of course well we'll delve into
that in a moment
i should start with the hard question i
suppose which is
well clearly people can say hateful
things and those things can be damaging
psychologically and physiologically i
suppose if people are stressed enough
and
the borderline is very difficult to
identify
um why is it that people shouldn't just
assume that you're
a mean loudmouth and that they shouldn't
pay any attention to you at all
because you're concerned about this i
mean
which is that's the general criticism of
critics of
of hate speech let's say and so why in
the world
aren't we aren't the people who are
putting this forward just trying to make
the world a nicer place what's the big
problem here
well i think a lot of people do assume
that i'm a mean loudmouth i think they
assume that about most
people who who defend freedom of speech
um but
and and i'm sure the latter part of your
question is is absolutely right insofar
as
i imagine a lot of the people who are
skeptical about free speech
are in fact trying to make the world a
better place so i don't think that's
mutually exclusive i mean
the the the problem here is that the
legislation as it currently stands here
means that for instance if you say
something critical about me
and i perceive that it was motivated by
hatred towards me
on the basis of my sexuality for
instance i could phone the police
and that would be recorded uh and would
appear on hate crime statistics in this
in this country because it's all about
perception that word is
used about five or six times within the
one passage in the in the hate crime
legislation the word perception
of the victim and again i say victim not
complaining which suggests
a complete disregard for due process but
i suppose we can leave that aside
but the most common the most common and
the most frightening misconception
i have found when it comes to people
defending free speech is that they are
doing so
because they want to have the right to
say appalling things about people
uh with no comeback whatsoever and they
want to go back to some imaginary
good old days you know where you could
just be casually homophobic and
racist and sexist and all the rest of it
and no one would call you out
for that now i don't know anyone who
falls into that category and and most
people who are
um you know advocating for free speech
are doing so precisely because they are
aware
that in countries where free speech
protections are meager
minorities tend to suffer the most and
in fact there is a a a
it seems to be a corollary to me that
those who are genuinely
for free speech are also for equal
rights and protecting the vulnerable in
society and this perception which i
really find unpleasant this perception
that if you are
standing up for this most foundational
of principles
of for freedom of speech if you're
standing up for that you can only be
doing so
if you have a nefarious motive i mean
what a horribly pessimistic view of
of humanity and and it seems to be well
it seems to be a direct
derivation of the hypothesis for example
that
all western social organizations
western are based on power and
are best conceived of as tyrannical and
so
if that's your view why would you not
assume that
most use of speech is essentially an
exercise of power
in the service of tyranny but then why
would you assume
uh that the government in control of any
particular uh country isn't part
of that tyranny that you're describing
it it seems odd to me
to be um mindful of the potential for
tyranny but then to outsource
all your individual liberties to the
state it seems contradictory to me
um well i guess the way that that is uh
um
elided over is by allowing
the hypothetical individual victim to
define the offense
this is the problem though this is i
mean the problem i've run into and this
is why
partly why i appreciated your book is
that increasingly
people are called upon to defend
fundamental
assumptions that were so taken for
granted that virtually no one has an
argument
that's fully articulated at hand
when no one questions free speech no one
has to defend it
thoroughly as soon as it's questioned
well it becomes an extraordinarily
complicated problem
the same with gender identity when it's
when no one's paying attention to it
it's obvious but as soon as you have to
think it through it becomes a
rat's nest to say the least when i was
in
the uk a few years ago i saw a number of
things that i felt were disturbing
um people seem to have accepted the
omnipresence of
cctv cameras to a degree that i found
horrifying frankly i don't like cctv
cameras i don't like
the the message they portray which is
that everyone is criminal enough so they
should be surveyed all the time
and someone needs to be watching i
noticed too in
london in particular that many buildings
had instituted airport level security so
that
you had to pass through a metal detector
and have your bags checked
etc while you were moving in and out of
buildings and
it it struck me as quite horrifying
given that as far as i'm concerned
great britain and it's legal and
parliamentary traditions
are the epicenter or at the epicenter of
western freedoms i mean
you could make a case for france i
suppose but not a strong one as far as
i'm concerned
yet this your citizens seem to have
accepted this with
virtually no problem and now
on the heels of that we have this
multiplication of
of hate crime that's as much a surprise
to me
as it as it is to you i mean you won't
have seen all of the cctv cameras
believe apparently they're absolutely
everywhere you can't walk anywhere
uh in the uk without being potentially
monitored
um you know i'm not saying someone's
watching you all the time but things are
being recorded and digitized
um yeah and it's it's interesting to me
because i remember back in the uh
in the early 2000s when the government
was trying to push through its id card
scheme and broadly speaking the left
were unanimously against it and they
didn't like this idea of living in a
society
where there's someone on the corner
saying papers please no one really
wanted that
but we've become very docile and very
accepting of the idea that we need to be
coddled and monitored by the state i
mean i know there's a recent debate
about vaccine passports and
people seem very blase about this idea
that that we might have to have
uh our id embedded and encoded onto a
card to get anywhere or to do anything
so i think there's there's something
going on there and it is connected with
what you've
brought up in terms of hate crime
legislation we've just become accustomed
i mean you mentioned specifically the
problem in scotland
and and seriously it relates very
closely to what you're saying because
the snp who are the only really
party with any clout in scotland that's
the scottish national party
um and it's never a good idea is it when
you have one political party which
doesn't really have an opposition
um they have a reputation for quite
nanny statueish policies you know they
they introduced a uh what was it called
the named person scheme it didn't go
through in the end but they wanted to
assign
every child born in scotland with a
state guardian you know they effectively
didn't trust
uh the parents to raise their own kids
they have other examples you know
minimum pricing on alcohol or
a ban on two for one pizzas because they
don't trust poor people
uh not to gain weight um so all sorts of
these sorts of policies but in this
current hate crime bill
which has just sailed through because
there's no opposition
uh hamza youssef the justice secretary
has pushed through he specifically
included
an element to this bill which says that
they can criminalize you for things you
say in the privacy of your own home
i mean that to me is i mean that's just
a given i would have never
thought that anyone in this country
would not consider that to be an
incredible invasion you can make a
strong case for
scotland as the uh ground zero for many
of
the developing many of the concepts that
undergird the entire western notion of
freedom and to see that emerging in
scotland is
absolutely stunningly terrifying as far
as i'm concerned you think of mel gibson
with a face covered in woad
shouting freedom as he's executed you
know in braveheart you do think of
scotland as being associated with it but
honestly scotland for some reason and i
don't know what it is and it might be to
do that it's effectively this one-party
state
it seems to have this incredible sense
and they've really bought into this idea
uh that unless they can police the
thought the thought and speech of their
citizens
then they will just run run a mock it's
there's another element to that bill i
don't know if you know about this
there's a specific element on the bill
which talks about the public performance
of a play so they've effectively said
that they will criminalize uh public
performances so say if
it can be deemed that those performances
were designed to stir up hatred that's
the formulation
stir up hatred i'm not quite sure what
that means necessarily but
the when when hamza youssef was
questioned about this in parliament
he actually said well theoretically a
neo-nazi or someone from the far right
could get together with a group of
actors and put on a play to
to recruit people to his cause and as i
said at the time
you know i don't know any neo-nazis but
they're not into amateur dramatics
that's not their thing they don't do
that
they wouldn't get involved and yet he's
got this idea in his head that that is a
feasible i mean it seems ridiculous
but it's not really because the
ramifications are quite are quite
serious and
and it and the way it's just gone
through without any opposition really
really
troubles me i mean there have been
modifications i should say in fairness
in the initial bill in the initial draft
of the bill they had said that you could
be criminalized irrespective of
intention
in other words yes that was terrifying
awful i mean
if you wrote a play that then stimulated
someone to join the far right then you
were still responsible whether you
intended it or not now the problem is
you know
with theatrical representation or any
kind of artistic representation is
sometimes you want to represent
the worst aspects of humanity because
that's part of drama and
literature and all the rest of it i mean
you would be there would be no artistic
freedom if that went through so
unfortunately
that element of the bill was modified
well and also the attempt to reverse the
idea that intent is important is
that's even that's even more uh
catastrophic
it it's always been a miracle to me that
our legal system
ever became psychologically
sophisticated enough
so that intent rather than outcome was
what mattered
because you have to be a sophisticated
thinker
to see that someone has done damage to
someone else
but and so the damage is real and marked
and
and troublesome and costly all of that
painful
but because the intent wasn't there
the severity of the action is
dramatically mitigated that's a sign of
maturity and sophistication to note that
and the fact that it's built into the
legal system
is nothing short of remarkable and then
to remove that and to
make the the felt consequences the
the arbiter of the reality of the
situation is
a dreadful assault on the integrity of
the law as such as far as i can tell
well moreover it's something that
everyone in intuitively understands we
all understand the difference between
murder and manslaughter
you know we all understand that intent
actually does like you say
escalate the the severity of a crime and
and
and it's bigger than that isn't it it's
because this like this idea that
intention doesn't matter is actually
built into
so much of this what we call social
justice discourse if you think of
critical race theory uh it's just a
given uh that there are racist
structures and you can be racist
without intending to be racist and i
really do dispute that
because i think in order to be racist
intention has to be at the heart of that
otherwise it's incoherent to me um but
but this is this is
really uh a degraded
view of humanity i feel where we are
effectively
like marionettes um and that we
we're just being played and that we
don't have any agency anymore and
therefore
uh we can't be responsible for our own
words
not not just our actions we can't be
responsible for our own words and
the ramifications so we have to be
controlled and we have to be
stifled by the state and it's very it
makes me very nervous
so i've been thinking through um
the importance of free speech i suppose
from a psychological perspective and
it seems to me that well we can walk
through some axioms and you can tell me
what you think about them if you would
so i mean the first thing we might
posit is that it's useful to think
it's better to think than not to think
and that might seem self-evident but
but thought can be troublesome and and
stir up trouble and your thoughts can be
inaccurate so it's perhaps not that
um unreasonable to start the questioning
there but
i think it was alfred north whitehead
who said that
thinking allows our thoughts to die
instead of us and so
he was thinking about the evolution of
thought in some sense from a biological
perspective so
imagine a creature that's incapable of
thought has to act
something out a representation of the
world or an intent it has to be embodied
and then if that fails well it fails in
action
and so the consequence of that might be
death it
might be very severe whereas once you
can think
you can represent the world abstractly
you can divorce the abstraction from the
world and then you can
produce avatars of yourself
sometimes in image like in dreams let's
say or in literature and fiction and
movies and so on
produce avatars of ourselves that are
fictional
and then run them as simulations in the
abstract world
and observe the consequences and
we do that in our stories we do that
when we dream
we do that when we imagine in images and
depict a dramatic scenario playing
itself out
but then we also do that in words
because we encode those images it's one
more level of abstraction we encode
those images into words
and those words become partial dramatic
avatars
and then the words can battle with one
another so
thought seems to work let's say verbal
thought
you ask yourself a question you receive
an answer
in some mysterious manner there's an
internal revelation of sorts
that's the spontaneous thought you know
when you sit down to write a book
thoughts come to you
perhaps because you pose yourself a
question and no one knows how that works
but
we experience it that thoughts manifest
themselves in the theater of our
imagination
so that's the revelatory aspect and then
there's the critical aspect which is
well now you've thought this and perhaps
you've written it down
can you generate counter positions are
are there universes that you can imagine
where this doesn't apply
are there situations where it doesn't
apply are there better ways of
formulating that thought
and but i would say with regard to
critical thought and to some degree with
regard to productive thought
an indeterminate proportion of that is
dependent on
speech i i don't think it's unreasonable
to point out that
thought is internalized speech and that
the dialectical process that constitutes
critical thinking
is internalized speech so you and i are
engaging in a dialectic enterprise
you'll pause it something and i'll
respond to it and you'll respond to that
and
we're we're we're in a kind of combat
there's some cooperation about it as
well
and we're attempting to formulate a
truth more clearly at least in principle
if we're being honest
we do that when we're speaking so our
thought the quality of our thought is
actually dependent on our ability to
speak
our minds absolutely and then go ahead
well i i couldn't agree more because i
think speech is the
way in which we collaborate on our
thoughts you know that that's how it how
it works you
you refine those thought processes that
you've described i mean i'm no
i'm no psychologist but i understand
this basic premise that that
we have these various thoughts that are
continually in conflict within ourselves
unless we're able to articulate them and
to engage in others through that process
through that transactional process of
speech
then those thoughts are never refined
and they remain in this kind of
infancy and this is yes they're as
refined as we can make them as
individuals
but that's also assuming that you even
have the words which you also learned in
the dialectical process
right exactly it's not as though the
truth is ever uh fully graspable but we
can we can get nearer to it through that
collaborative process of speaking and
articulating the thoughts and in fact
even in the act of like you say writing
or articulating yourself
uh as with your self-authoring program
for instance the act of writing things
out
is what clarifies the points of view for
you i've actually found that the
the the the way that i think about these
issues now
is largely a product of of the fact that
i've written so much about it
and change my mind through the act of
learning how to express myself
on these points and and and the and the
consequence of not having
that opportunity i think is uh
something i would barely want to
contemplate and i think that
to give an example of of uh of the
moment which is that
because any kind of attempt to have a
discussion or debate about the perceived
conflict between
trans rights and gender critical
feminism because to even attempt that
discussion at the moment
will have such uh grave social
consequences and certainly
in terms of career prospects major
consequences people will not have that
discussion i have
people i know in politics in the media
and they say to me quite honestly i will
not
talk about this i have concerns i have
qualms i want answers to questions but i
absolutely will not open my mouth about
this and if you don't do that
uh this is why no one understands the
issue this is why no one has reached any
kind of consensus on this issue
all we have is a sense in which to have
the quote unquote wrong opinion
makes you a pariah uh and therefore i'd
better not have that opinion well then
that's not a sincerely held conviction
that's just if the definition of wrong
is continually transforming and in an
unpredictable manner then it's best just
to sidestep the issue entirely
and then that leaves it murky and
ill-defined and
assuming that you believe that thought
has any utility and so when you're
sitting down to write when i'm sitting
down to write
and i produce a sentence you know it
might have come from some theoretical
perspective maybe i'm approaching
something from a
freudian perspective or a marxist
perspective or
or an enlightenment perspective etc i
mean
it's it's a it's a it's a psychological
trope i suppose that
we all think the thoughts of dead
philosophers right we think we have our
own opinions but
that's really rarely very very very
rarely the case
it's not that easy to come up with
something truly original and generally
make incremental progress at best
and so your ability to abstractly
represent the world and then to generate
avatars that can be defeated without you
dying is dependent on your incorporation
of a multitude of opinions
and that in itself is a consequence of
i mean that works to the degree that
communication is actually free and that
you can get access to as much thought as
you can possibly manage so
i can't see how you can deny the
centrality
of free speech as a fundamental right or
the fundamental right perhaps
unless you simultaneously deny the
utility of thought
but maybe if you are also inclined to
remove the individual from the central
position of the political discourse
then maybe you can also
make the case at least implicitly that
individual thought doesn't matter and
that mostly it's just causing trouble
but i think individual thought is key
and actually even in the the the outline
you've described there
there isn't there is individual agency
in reaching a conclusion that has been
articulated before
insofar as if you are engaged with a
multitude of writers and philosophers
and artists and ideas
and you've come out with a perspective
well that perspective may not be
original to you
but the process that you've gone through
to reach that viewpoint is individual to
you
you know it there is a power in that
there's something important about that
you know there's something crucial it's
if you're a practicing psychotherapist
one of the things you have to learn is
to not
provide people with your words too much
what you want is for them to formulate
the
conclusion and you can guide them
through the process of investigation you
talked about the self-authoring process
and
which is online at selfauthoring.com
that it steps people say through the
process of writing an autobiography
of analyzing their current virtues and
faults and of
making a future plan the utility of all
of that is dependent on
the the person who's um
undertaking the exercise generating
their own
verbal representations right and that
seems to cement it somehow
as yours if you've come up with the
words
and so it's that it's the uppermost
expression of
personhood the ability to
have the words that you should speak
reveal themselves to you and to have the
right to express them as you see fit
yes in which case if you if you are
merely repeating an accepted script
then then to what extent can you say to
can you even say to be an individual at
all
you know this this to me well i think
that's part of the philosophical
conundrum is that
if you believe that all people do is
repeat
predigested scripts especially if
your view is that the fundamental human
motivation is power
and the entire social landscape is
nothing but a competition between
equally what would you say selfish and
single-minded
powers drivers then there is no
individual there's no individual in that
conceptual world
and it seems to me that that's the world
that
we're being pushed to inhabit
and are criticized for on moral grounds
for criticizing
and i'm still trying to get my hands
around this i mean when i went to
britain
i saw the cttv cameras and the increased
security
and it isn't clear to me how that's
related to the social
justice issues the so-called social
justice issues that we're discussing but
they seem to me in some very difficult
to comprehend way part and parcel of the
same thing the same dangerous thing
well i think it's probably connected
just in terms of this distrust of
humanity or this belief that that
um people need to be shepherded uh other
otherwise
left to their own devices uh chaos will
reign i think that's
i think that's the connection it's not
directly connected as far as
the issues relating to liberty and cctv
obviously predate
uh what we now call whatever the current
social justice movement is called
uh but i think there is there is
something there i mean
th the censorship the the impulse to
censor what people read
and this is something that particularly
hits home to me in the arts
is based on this view that ultimately
it's the people are
the or the populous is uh liable to
corruption
if they're exposed to the wrong
materials and and
what's very interesting to me about that
i mean you've written a lot about the
way in which
literature uh for instance informs our
experiences because it is in a sense
like when you read philosophers your
you're feeling your way through other
lives and other experiences that are
trans historical and cross-cultural
and they inform the way that you react
in your own individual
experience but if you start to say as an
artist no you can only represent
for a start what you personally are or
have experienced
and you cannot represent anything which
is morally problematic to use the phrase
that they absolutely adore
then art fails to and literature in
particular fails to
uh function in the way that it should
because you can't explore
those things this is why i often when it
comes when it comes to
censorship of the arts i often go back
to what oscar wilde said about this he
said there's no such thing
as a moral or an immoral book books are
well written or badly written
that is all and that and that actually
art and morality
uh sometimes are not one in other words
art shouldn't just be
about promoting whatever the uh ethical
trend is of any given time it's much
bigger it's not art at that point
at all as far as i'm concerned if you if
you can
state the purpose of the art in explicit
terms
especially if it's in accordance with a
uh
let's say an ideology that's shared by a
multitude of people
it's not art at all it's propaganda it's
it's totally bernard i mean
this is why so many people are getting
sick of hollywood i mean to bring it
down to a different level that people
are sick of the entertainment on their
tv on their streaming services
and on hollywood because they have this
constant feeling that they're being
hectic
by some moralistic person in a studio
saying you know we
our focus here is on diversity our focus
here is on a
um the right moral message that the the
message of the story is one that would
be approved by a group of intersectional
activists and you get this all the time
seeping into mainstream entertainment
and people get really really sick of it
it's not that when you see
a lesbian kiss in star wars that offends
you because you're a homophobe
most most sci-fi fans are they've never
had a problem with diversity or anything
like that
what bothers them about it is this sense
of someone saying to them
we think you're all evil bigots and you
need to be educated and that's why we're
going to shoehorn
in a lesbian kiss into the end of this
film that's why people have
a problem i mean you you had it yourself
recently with that ludicrous marvel
comics thing where you became the red
skull
uh and that to me was a perfect example
of the banality
of uh an artistic endeavor that becomes
an exercise
uh in political pedagogy because that
was quite clearly
i mean you couldn't even say it was
satirical because
it it cannot be satirically effective if
the thing that they are comparing you to
is the precise opposite of the thing you
believe i mean of all the sort of public
figures i can think of
you have uh the most clear track record
of opposing tyranny in
all its forms which anyone who knows
anything about your work will know
you've spent years lecturing about the
evils of authoritarianism including
nazism
so the idea that you would then become
this super magic
nazi is is is propagandistic
it's it's it's totally banal
artistically
firstly you can't you it's not
satirically right um but also it's just
it's just it's just you know what it
reminds me of actually i don't know if
you
if you remember after the fatwa against
salman rushdie um
there was a film made in pakistan called
international guerrillas
where they turned salman rushdie into
this evil
um villain playboy who was colluding
with the
israeli military services and at the end
of the film these flying
copies of the quran float down and shoot
laser beams into his head and kill him
off
but and that is such a ridiculous
laughable film you know you put your
enemy as the main villain and you just
misrepresent him in that way well that's
just what they did to you it's as banal
as that
and that's i think people are sick of
that well the response
thankfully seems to indicate that no it
didn't
did people it didn't do me any harm as
far as i can tell
i mean it was very um shocking to me
that it happened
it took me about 12 hours to sort of
regain my composure because i actually
couldn't believe it to begin with i i
was sure that it was a fabrication
yeah especially but then it was even
more shocking when i found out who
who authored it you know it wasn't it
was someone who had an
intellectual reputation and so
but he's an activist isn't he he's a
he's an intersectional activist
he definitely his opinions definitely
place him on the radical
on the side of the radical left so
it it's very difficult to so there's
there's a there's an
attack on on the essence of free speech
i mean i remember
reading dereda darada criticized
our culture western culture has foul
logo centric
yeah and it's really actually quite a
precise word
so the phallic part of it is masculine
obviously
related to the phallus to the and
logos is well that's the central
concept of greek rationalism but it's
also the central concept of christianity
and
the logos is something like the magical
power of
genuine and true speech it's something
like that and
there are representations of the magical
power of speech
that predate greece and christianity you
see it in mesopotamia
that this the equivalent to the savior
and
ancient mesopotamian uh religious
thinking was marduk and he could speak
magic words he had eyes all around all
the way around his head
which meant that he paid attention to
everything but he could speak magic
words and um and and so that idea
of the of the centrality of speech to
the
and its association with the very fabric
of reality
that that's been an idea that has
strived to make itself manifest for
thousands and thousands of years
i mean in in the judeo-christian
tradition in the biblical tradition
the word is given cosmological status
as the thing that brings habitable order
out of
chaos and it's identified with divinity
itself and so
the assault on free speech is an assault
on a principle that's fundamental beyond
say it's centrality it's central
importance to the enlightenment
and is it it's it's an assault on the
on the idea of the logos itself i agree
this is why i always mistrusted the the
the post-structuralist when i was
studying for english it was the daradan
foucault and liotarden
these were taken as a given and this
idea that there's no there is no truth
beyond language you know language is all
language the way in which we construct
our perception of reality and our
perception of truth
and and actually there is no truth at
the heart of it i just found it so
depressing depressingly pessimistic
because it also means that you construct
can construct any kind of reality you
like and it and
and maybe that's part of the motivation
for it is
the the the hypothetical lack of
constraint
by anything that that seems to imply
right i mean if there's no canonical
reality
well there's no responsibility that's
for sure
you could argue that there's no meaning
and it's deeply pessimistic but maybe
the payoff for that is no responsibility
but there's also no constraint of any
sort there's certainly no ethical
constraint
and i mean i keep trying to dig to see
what's
at the bottom of this uh this anti-logo
sentiment and it's a very
it's a very difficult thing to make to
make it right
maybe it's not even as deliberate as the
way that it sounds
maybe it is just the fact that that
these theories for whatever reason
became
fashionable in universities about 20
years ago and now for whatever reason
they have
um escaped into the mainstream and and
you know i mean most of the people that
push this stuff
don't read foucault and they don't know
about the
the people whose ideas they've they've
imbibed and actually very much
misunderstood you know i mean
the whole point of the post-modernist
was to to to to trash
the notion of grand narratives and what
we have now in the social justice
movement is an incredible grand
narrative you know we are
we are on the right side of history we
are the righteous ones and everyone else
needs to be
uh you know decimated and it's it's it
it it seems to me
that this stuff i i don't think it's as
conspiratorial as that i think it's just
sort of
circumstances of history one thing after
another and this is where we we're at
now
but the end result that we have to deal
with which i think you've alluded to is
this idea
that if there is no such thing as
reality beyond language then you are
at liberty to just to construct whatever
a
pseudo-reality that you desire or is
easiest for you
and we see elements of this
reverberating i think in a lot of the
discourse at the moment of things like
lived experience you know you can
present as much data as you want
but it will be disregarded if it doesn't
tally with what lived experience really
means which is what i want to be
true well there's also this insistence
that seems part of it that
i mean i i objected to some legislation
that was passed in canada and
that's sort of what propelled me into
public
visibility let's say and to begin with i
was
mostly concentrating on the violation of
the principle of free speech that the
legislation seemed to me to represent
because it compelled certain utterances
and
i was never a fan of hate speech laws to
begin with
and and this was something beyond hate
speech
laws because hate speech laws stop you
from saying things
whereas compelled speech laws force you
to say something which is
much worse even though the first one is
also
inadvised ill-advised as far as i'm
concerned but
i i've realized more recently that i was
also disturbed
although in a less explicit manner with
the
theory of identity that was an implicit
part of the legislation
so with gender identity for example and
we're engaged in
a discussion across our culture about
gender identity
i mean i know as a personality
psychologist that
there are females biological females who
have masculine personalities and there
are biological males who have feminine
personalities
that the link between personality as
such and
and biological structure is
suggestive but not absolute and there's
a lot of variability
um but the idea that identity is
something that you define
yourself and that you can change
at will at any point seems to me to be
entirely counterproductive and dangerous
because it's
inaccurate so your identity isn't
merely your membership in
whatever group you happen to identify
with at that moment it's certainly not
merely your sexuality or merely your
race in fact
your identity is barely your race
because your identity is something more
like
how you conduct yourself in the world
and if you define yourself as black
let's say that doesn't give you much of
a map
to encountering and approaching the
world it's not nowhere near
detailed enough and
and then the idea that you define it
i i've been thinking about that a lot
you never define your identity by
yourself
you can't because you're surrounded by
other people and
they have to play along with you and
if they don't play along with you
voluntarily which means they appreciate
the quality of your game and they
understand it then
you're either going to be alienated or
you have to impose your identity by
force but that's also not a very good
solution i mean
i just spent some time interviewing one
of the world's foremost authorities on
aggression and that'll be released in in
a bit
perhaps it's been released before this
will be released
he's done longitudinal studies of
aggression and if the idea that
our social structures are predicated on
power
was true then children would start out
not being aggressive and they would
become more aggressive with time and the
more aggressive children would be more
successful
and none of that is true children start
out more aggressive than they are
on average by the time they're adults
aggressive
aggression levels decrease with age
rather than increasing and there's no
evidence whatsoever that it's a
a useful long-term strategy in the
social world
identity is something you negotiate the
way you negotiate a game
yeah it's more it has to be that way
it's just
there's something rather sinister isn't
there about the way in which present day
identity
politics is about imposition on to
others
uh rather than an assertion of who
who i am or whatever that might be i
mean i i always mistrusted him so i can
see the
the uh utility of identity politics
politically speaking
uh in in scenarios where people are
marginalized you know i understand why
gay people collectively
came together back in the 60s to fight
for their rights because there was a
obviously a serious problem or the civil
rights movement in northern ireland in
the 60s and 70s and that kind of thing
uh where catholics weren't able to to
have the vote or to get housing
so that sort of makes sense to me the
current identity
politic or what we might call
identitarians a lot of it strikes me
as about as about power in fact i feel
like they would be
an incredible subject for foucault if he
were alive today
because i've noticed this correlation
and a lot of people have noticed this
correlation and i never get an answer
about this
but why is it whenever online whenever
i'm viciously attacked or threatened
something
particularly pernicious the person doing
it
always has their pronouns in their bio
or a rainbow
gay flag in their bio why is there a
correlation that i've experienced again
and again i mean
it's it's almost inevitable at this
point between uh
the need to self-identify in terms of
sexuality and gender and a kind of
cruelty
or viciousness or a need to attack an
aggression
one of the things that that disturbs me
constantly about
ideological representations of
of the world broadly speaking is that
their fundamental danger is that they
always contain a too convenient
theory of evil and malevolence and
for me any theory that locates the
fundamental problem of evil
somewhere other than inside you is
dangerous now that isn't to say that
social structures can't be corrupted
and aren't corrupt it's that's an
existential problem in and of itself
it's
it's always the case that our social
institutions aren't what they should be
and they're outdated and they're
predicated to some degree on deceit
and people who use power can manipulate
them
sometimes successfully that problem
never
goes away and it never will but the
when when the evil can be easily located
somewhere else
then you have every moral right
to allow your unexamined motivations to
manifest themselves fully because you
can punish the evil doers
and always remain on the moral side of
the fence there's a huge attractiveness
in that
i think i mean this is something you've
explored a lot with the idea from the
soldier nitsan's idea about the good and
evil cutting through the heart of every
human
every human being because that that to
me
uh it really gets to the heart of a lot
of of what i would call a kind of
infantile culture i think this is a
symptom
of of of of childishness you know
whenever i was learning about literature
and and what constituted more
sophisticated literature and what didn't
disney films childish films let's take
tolkien for instance good people
look oh sorry bad people look bad they
look like orcs they're ugly
and they are villains and then there are
heroes and they are good there isn't
complexity and if you have a more
complex novel like a mervyn peak novel
where people aren't necessarily good or
bad they're both they struggle within
themselves and with other people
that is a mark of a kind of adult novel
as opposed to a
a childish novel right and that that's
quite an important distinction and i
think
most of the political and ideological
battles that i find myself in the middle
of and i'm sure you do as well
are because people are just reducing
everything to this binary of good versus
evil
and putting themselves on the side of
good it it is a very
infantile almost um almost like a
caricature of religion
you know it's it's uh it's and i see it
again and again we had it in this
country with the brexit vote
effectively what happened in the vote
here and the reason why it became so
toxic and families fell apart and
you know you wouldn't believe i know it
wasn't reported very much elsewhere but
it was like a kind of ideological civil
war here
but not a very sophisticated one because
it came down to this narrative that if
you voted to leave the eu you were evil
racist stupid and if you voted to remain
you were you were good and progressive
and and all the rest and noble and
virtuous right
and of course there are all sorts of
good reasons to have voted either way
and and this kind of
caricature and it happens again with
well you described
you described it as a caricature of of
religion
and i think that's what an ideology is
and
this is one of the reasons that i've
been inclined let's say to
go to have my shot at the rational
atheists
much as i'm a fan of enlightenment
thinking i mean i was convinced
as a consequence of reading jung as
primarily but also dostoevsky and also
nietzsche
primarily and solzhenitsyn i would say
as well
that and then biology as well as i
studied that more deeply
there's no escaping a religious
framework there's no way out of it
and you if you eliminate it
say as a consequence of rational
criticism
what you inevitably produce is its
replacement by
forms of religion that are much less
sophisticated i mean
well it's not a religion it's it's a
it's a fundamentalist really it's
you know if i look back to my catholic
upbringing actually acknowledge
acknowledging your own capacity for sin
is at the heart of catholicism that's
why we have the confessional
that's why you sit there and tell this
stranger all these things you've done
wrong
because it's recognizable well that and
that's
that's far from trivial it's
unbelievably not trivial
and because it was so common like a
common part of catholicism it can be
passed over without notice
and so religious the religious
structures that we inherited
i'm going to talk about christianity
most specifically because
it's the dominant form of it's the it's
the form of religious belief that
primarily undergirds our social
structures
it's our operating system my my producer
came up with that term the other day and
i thought it was apt
um and it does localize the drama
between good and evil
inside and makes you responsible for
that
and and makes you
encourages you let's say to attend to
the ways that you fall short of the
ideal and
when you criticize a structure like that
out of existence you don't
criticize the questions that gave rise
to it out of existence
and the questions might be well what's
the nature of the good
what's the nature of evil those are
religious questions what's the purpose
of our life
how do you orient yourself if you're
trying to move up
let's say rather than down how should
you conduct yourself etc etc those
questions don't go away
and they can't not be answered and so
the way that a traditional religious
structure
answers them is in a mysterious way it
uses ritual it uses music it uses
art it uses literature it uses stories
all these things that are outside the
realm of easy criticism
and then some of that's translated into
you know comprehensible explicit dogma
and that's the part that's most
susceptible to rational criticism
but when that disappears i've been
thinking about this a lot this week
because of what happened to richard
dawkins
recently you know and i have my
differences with dawkins and the rest of
the russian atheists because i think
that they
underestimated the danger of dispensing
with what they were attempting to
dispense with and
i see the influx of religious
fervor associated with political ideas
as
a direct consequence of of the lack of
separation let's say between church and
state
psychologically but but dawkins has
fallen foul of
this new religion but a religion but his
case
actually really is his testimony to what
we're talking about that this is not a
religion in a traditional sense it is an
infantile religion that only sees things
in binaries of good and evil because
he was effectively he was posing a
question about
identity he was saying if it is possible
for rachel dolezal to identify as black
why is she universally uh condemned
and derided uh but somebody can identify
as the opposite sex
and they are celebrated and all he was
doing was posing the question he wasn't
even
actually making a claim yeah well he was
doing he was doing what a scientist
actually does i mean i've been shocked
frequently in my interactions with
journalists because
i've worked as a scientist for three
decades and i'm accustomed to
the way that scientists think and speak
and when i'm sitting around with my
graduate students and there's a problem
or an issue
what they do my colleagues as well is
generate a bunch of hypotheses about why
that might be
they don't necessarily believe them but
that the first trick is to generate as
many
um what would you say hypotheses i said
that already
that might account for it ranging from
biological through social etc
and that is exactly what dawkins did he
even said that's what he was doing
that puts you on the side of the devil i
mean there was a viral tweet this week
from a teacher saying
i will never allow my pupils to play
devil's advocate i will never allow that
in the class because some some views are
oppressive and
and are not to be entertained i mean but
that's the point that's why the vatican
will call in a devil's advocate when
someone is potentially being
canonized well if you can't play devil's
advocate you can't
think that's it you have to have devil a
devil's
advocate in your head if you don't have
a devil's advocate in your head
torturing every thought you generate
you're not you're not engaged in
critical thinking right
that's for sure that's the scientific
process to disprove yourself i mean
that's
that's what surprises me about uh
richard dawkins response because
i think what he didn't realize is that
he was caught in this good versus evil
binary and he had
he had he was the heretic now uh he had
been branded he posed the
question you're not you're not meant to
pose uh and therefore he's
he's now outed himself as one of the
demons
he's there in pandemonium with the other
demons now the
so he then he of course backtracked and
apologized and said well i didn't want
to
offend anyone and of course in a in an
adult rational world that would be
taken in good faith and and what but he
didn't i don't think he fully
appreciates what's going on here
is that he's already uh marked himself
as
well here's his here's his apology let's
say
now what he should have said as far as
i'm concerned here's what he said
okay um i do not intend
to disparage trans people i see that my
academic
disgust question has been misconstrued
as such
and i deplore this it was also not my
attempt to ally
in any way with republican bigots in the
u.s
now exploiting this issue and so okay
it's so interesting that that's what he
did
because well it's buying any tribalism
thing
you know well it's also it's it's not a
it's not the best response for
to defend him what he should have said
was something like
look people here's something to think
about that i was
posing that's what scientists do and
you didn't understand that but that's
not my problem it's your lack of
sophistication but
he instead of saying that
he immediately removed himself from the
bad people
and that was the republican bigots which
just seems to me
to pour fuel on the fire and
and then he also said that he didn't
intend to disparage
trans people which isn't the issue at
all well also
there's no implication in what he asked
that he had ever intended to disparage
trans people but
to be fair to him to be fair to him i
understand when you're caught in the
middle of a twitter storm
you you just want it to stop and i've
heard you talk about this as well it's
actually
your response probably isn't going to be
the best the best one you just want it
to go away oh well look i mean one of
the things that's really worth pointing
out here and i it's not like i don't
have sympathy for dawkins i have
sympathy for dawkins i
sent out a tweet defending him yesterday
i mean dawkins is an admirable scientist
in my estimation i learned lots from
reading his books
um that doesn't mean i don't have my
criticisms of dawkins
but just because you have criticisms of
someone doesn't mean that
they've never done anything worthwhile
or that you haven't learned something
from them
and that's especially true in the
scientific realm um
i just don't understand why
okay so back to the twitter issue so
what i've seen repeatedly and and this
is worth
some discussion is when i'm watching
twitter when i'm watching these attacks
on people
what i've seen the most general pattern
of response to be is that
it doesn't take very many people
attacking you on twitter
before it's seriously psychologically
disturbing
yeah you know and that is interestingly
related to this whole issue of hate
speech that we've been discussing
because
it is the case that vicious attacks have
a
quite a pronounced psychological effect
especially if they're personal and
people generally fold and apologize
instantly
if my my sense has been if the twitter
mob is 20 people
it's sort of like they're reacting to 20
of their neighbors showing up on their
doorsteps with pitchforks and
and um torches and i think it's
it's actually an admirable response in
some sense because
a well-socialized person actually does
care what their neighbors think and if
you offend 20 of your neighbors
it's possible 20 of your tribe it's
possible that you've done something
wrong you might ask yourself that now
on twitter you're connected to hundreds
of thousands of people and if you would
offend 20 it's not clear what that means
it might just mean that you said
something it feels a lot worse than it
actually is as well it feels amplified
because there's all these people who are
strangers who know absolutely nothing
about you
and it's particularly frustrating
because more often than not when it's
happened to me it's always been
an imagined grievance it's not actually
something i've said it's something that
they've
assumed that i've said or or a way that
they have interpreted this and and
the more you try and fight back against
it or try and explain your actual
position
the more they double down on their you
know and you've had this as well people
are going after a figment of their own
imagination that's impossible to fend
off
you know and and it does do
psychological harm and i've never denied
that and this is something i addressed
in the book because i i quoted
i can't remember her name now but the
writer talking about how hate speech
uh could be said to be violence insofar
as the psychological impact can have
it can have a physiological impact it
can make you sick it can make you unwell
the the impact of words
but of course that well the example i
use is uh is taxation i could
become full physically sick because i'm
under stress from being overly taxed by
the government
does that mean that the government has
committed an act of violence against me
it could be applied to absolutely
anything i think
well an anarchist would argue yes right
sure exactly but but that wouldn't be me
um and but that but you could apply that
to absolutely any conceivable scenario
where anything that has happened to you
has led to uh stress and and physical
degeneration and so i don't think it's
right to single speech out and say
speeches that but we can say
it's a one-sided argument because
dangerous as
speech free speech is we don't ever have
to deny that there's such a thing as
hateful speech or damaging speech
or corrosive speech or untruth speech or
pathological speech in in every possible
direction
that isn't the issue the issue is
what's more dangerous to regulate it or
to leave it be
despite its dangers that's the only
rational
argument the only even if you have the
most
uh repugnant character who is advocating
the most vile
ideas about society and attempting to
proselytize even someone who's
attempting to recruit people to his or
her
cause um even something as vicious as
neo-nazism or something like that
the question isn't you know do i support
what that person is saying because
obviously we don't
the question is do you take a few
instances
of people behaving in this way uh and
use that as
a reason a justification to empower the
state
to make a decision about what people can
say and think that's the bigger
principle that's
at stake here i worry that with with
social media and twitter
as well is that we we end up buying into
the illusion that there are more hateful
people in the world than there actually
are
because even the people who send these
hateful things probably wouldn't behave
like that in real life there's something
about
the online world and what it does is
absolutely
i mean this is the heart of cancer
culture this is why it works like you
said it's just a few tweets
that's all it takes i've seen situations
where companies and corporations will
backtrack on a policy
just because of one or two tweets
because they fear
this this deluge of of of people they
it has such disproportionate power
and often with this this kind of council
culture it is often
about something that someone hasn't even
said the example of dawkins is is
perfect because
a lot of the people and some prominent
people i saw were saying look dawkins
has now outed himself as a transphobe
if you said if she said where are you
tomorrow buckle well quite because if if
someone is transphobic simply because
you've decided that
you know i mean it was the same with jk
rowling uh it became
suddenly quite normal for commentators
on the mainstream media to say that she
has said transphobic things
well where because i've read her
comments and her essay
on the trans issue that she posted on
her blog and it was a long uh
essay which was very compassionate and
nuanced and at no point
it's the opposite she says that she
supports trans rights and she would
stand there against any discrimination
if you and i've been in these fights all
the time if ever you ask someone to say
can you just quote
the transphobic thing that she said they
never can
and an adult would say okay i can't find
the evidence of my preconception so
therefore i should revise
my view but they don't they they they
double down on it and they find
these sort of they use kazoo stream
whatever linguistic
uh semantic tricks they can to come back
round
to the to the conclusion they'd already
decided same with with dawkins i mean
not just the american humanist
association i saw a major blogger
saying that anyone who is defending him
is transphobic and like well
if that's all it takes to be smeared in
this way if it doesn't matter what you
say
if all that matters is what people
decide that you believe then
then i suppose this goes back to this
pseudo-reality we were discussing
i guess what what dawkins got in trouble
for let's take it apart a bit okay
because it's worth
it's worth doing he said this is his
original tweet
in 2015 rachel dolezal a white chapter
president
of naacp was vilified
for identifying as black some men
choose to identify as women and some
women choose
to identify as men you will be vilified
if you deny that they literally are what
they identify as
discuss okay so we put forth a set of
propositions
but the proposition has a point
and the point is what is it that you can
and can't identify with and
what what power do people have to
enforce their decision on others
and that's really that's really the
question he's asking if you strip it
down and that is actually
a question that's very threatening to
well let's see who would it be
threatening to what would be threatening
to anyone who insists that
you can choose an identity say in the
realm of of gender
and that you should have the right to
enforce your choice
despite other people's opinions let's
say
he's asking why is there an inherent
contradiction in the intersectional
discourse why is it why is it that
racial identity is not malleable and in
fact has to be strictly police
hence why we have all these debates
about cultural appropriation
why is that so rigid and yet even if the
lived experience let's go back to that
the lived experience of the person tells
them otherwise i mean rachel dolezal
wrote a whole book in which she outlines
how she
feels that she has always been black it
isn't just i choose to be black one day
it is something
her lived experience is that in essence
she is
so why is that to be vilified
universally without question and there's
no discussion to be had here
and yet someone who chooses uh
in other words what that gender identity
is something that is malleable
and open to options and actually
infinite
uh options why and i i think maybe he's
vilified because he asked a question
that's at the heart of the problem with
identity
politics period it's i mean particularly
because when it comes to race i mean
virtually all intersectionists would
accept that race is socially constructed
this is something they're always talking
about
and so therefore in a sense there is
more of a case for transracialism
if if you want to say that you can you
that it is an identity that that can be
mixed well in some sense we already
accept transracialism as a given and so
here's something i might as well get in
trouble for this
um well if your
ancestry is 95
caucasian and 5 non-caucasian
asian black let's say
you're not caucasian right generally
speaking you can identify with the
minority group and so
at some point the question becomes well
it's a ridiculous question which which
is why the whole notion of group
identity construed in this way is so
pathological
but we obviously accept some degree of
trans-racial identification if
your racial group is disproportionately
in one category but
you identify with the other and that's
instantly not only accepted it's it's
standard practice
right and i'm with the intersectionists
on this insofar as race is we're all the
same i
you know ever since we've broken down
the human genome we know there are no
differences between us
so this idea uh that it must be so
rigidly police this this
this social construct these arbitrary
ideas and yet gender i mean
i think it's something okay so now we
know why now we know exactly why dawkins
got himself in somewhere well true okay
you know he put his finger well no it
will for sure
for sure but but the magical super nazis
are always in trouble so
you are exactly you know exactly but
then what but with with the question of
uh
of the tr the gender identity debate but
this is the debate we need to be having
is actually the other thing he put his
finger on
there is that actually people are
arguing with different definitions in
their heads
you know for for uh um for the
identitarians the idea of a woman
a woman is an identity it isn't a
biological reality
uh but for most for most people the
classification of woman
is biological reality not identity so in
other words
and why can i why why is it that we
cannot have that discussion so okay so
you believe this thing we believe the
other
uh and that's why we're at loggerheads
uh but but let's let's have the
discussion why can that not happen why
does it have to be
if you've decided that's what we're
that's actually what we're trying to
unpack is what's the motivation at the
root of this and it seems to me
i do believe it's something like a
pronounced infantilism i mean one of the
things i've been toying with is the idea
that
the the gender that the demand
for gender fluidity
in late adolescence let's say
is something like the consequence of
insufficient fantasy play in childhood
that that i remember for example when my
son was little
his sister and her friends used to dress
him up as a fairy
princess they did this with some
regularity and i kind of cast a dim eye
on that but
i thought it through and you know it
sort of disturbed me and then i thought
it through and i thought wait a second
here
leave the kid alone leave the girls
alone he is playing out what it means to
be female in
dramatic play and he needs to do that
because otherwise he can't understand
what it means to be female
that's how children understand that's
how adults understand things for god's
sake we go to a movie and we watch
someone
play out of female and we identify with
that because otherwise we wouldn't be
enjoying the movie and we get
we get a bit of a clue about what it's
like to inhabit someone else's skin
so there's this necessity for play in
gender roles and
that has to manifest itself and
if the play has been interrupted let's
say by electronic equipment
for example or or or
any of the other things that might be
interrupting it well maybe that desire
comes back with
a vengeance later and i i have to be
whoever i say i am i have to be able to
play with this and
well if it's a developmental requirement
there's going to be a lot of insistence
behind it and
it looks immature and it is because it
should have happened earlier most people
stabilize their gender identity by the
time they're three or four
but it doesn't always happen so
there isn't infantilism in this demand
for for
fluidity of identity uh this insistence
that other people play the game that i
insist they're going to play
and then what about the idea that the
gender critical feminists would come in
and say well
the idea of dress a boy dressing up in a
dress there's nothing inherently
female about that or feminine about that
in any case that all of this is
a construct anyway and why can't we let
the kids just
some kids are not gender conforming and
they can just do what they want i mean
the the the concern i have with the
current
identity obsessed ideology is that they
see a boy in a dress
and they will say well he could
potentially be a woman
and by doing so are reinforcing the most
conservative
views of of gender to begin with um
and that to me see well that that i i'm
intuitively against that because i
wasn't a gender conforming i didn't
play football with the other boys you
know i didn't i mean i didn't dress up
in dresses but i may have done if they
were lying around
you know i i i i've i've i find it very
odd
that this supposedly progressive radical
movement
uh is so dependent on the idea of
of very very traditional unyielding
notions of what it is
to be male and what it is to be female
yeah but only in the case where
the identity is across the the sex
it that that it so you can be
if if you're a man who believes he's a
woman
that's inviolable and has a biological
reference point but if you're a woman
who thinks she's a woman it doesn't
it's completely malleable and so you
know that's an inherent contradiction
again and that's
that's and it's work and it's worthy of
discussion surely and
and the contradiction doesn't just go
away because you won't allow the
conversation to happen
which no the contradiction gets played
out in in actuality
if you don't allow it to be dealt with
in abstraction
so then the question is how do we break
through
and i mean this is something i've been
really really thinking about is that
it isn't no it's no longer just a matter
of trying to persuade
people it's almost trying to
de-radicalize people at this point how
do
how do i explain to someone the world
isn't this fantasy world that you've
created in your head where it's just
it's full of transphobes and neo-nazis
and all these
and good versus evil the world is
actually much more complex and nuanced
and requires discussion and thought
how do you break through someone's
fantasy so that we can have that
discussion
well it used to be that you sent them to
the university so they could study the
humanities
that's the last thing you should do now
well that was the answer i mean
that was the whole point right to to
make people more sophisticated in their
conceptions and
in which cases is it the case that it's
over now if
if people were to be educated out of
those problems
and now that actually the the higher
education itself has become so
ideologically driven that to go to
university means you end up
more indoctrinated than when you went
there what what hope is there i feel
like i'm
i sound a bit frustrated here but i feel
like i'm bashing my head a bit against a
brick wall because
half most of the time when i'm caught in
an argument with with these
ideologues they are arguing like i said
with a monster they've created in their
own heads i'm not the person they think
i am i don't have the values they think
i have
and and therefore the the discussion is
stymied from the outset and it does make
me very frustrated and
that's probably the real reason i wrote
the book actually because i want
i want the idea of free speech to be
elevated again as a sacrosanct principle
so that we can have these conversations
and so that people don't get demonized
and
attacked for things they don't believe
and and so that we can
reach some kind of consensus uh on these
issues that we've been describing these
contentious issues because when you have
an issue that's particularly tendentious
you
it requires more conversation it
requires more discussion and more
understanding and
i don't think we're getting that at the
moment yeah well i guess i'm
somewhat optimistic about that because i
can see all the possibility that
long-form conversations of this sort
bring well there's an appetite for them
isn't it but but is there an appetite
for them
from the activists and the ideologues
who have seized so much control in our
major
education i think i think so i think so
i mean
i've been struck by how
how deep the hunger is for for genuine
conversation and and very much heartened
by it
and so that's a counter movement
i hope you're right i i just don't see
any evidence of that
from the people i'm talking about i
don't see it from the people who will
say
educate
it's never the same people and that that
plays with us psychologically because
of course we are built to more or less
assume that we're interacting with a
continuous community
yeah and and we aren't we're we're we're
interacting with a discontinuous
community on twitter and so
we're led astray in our presuppositions
constantly
and but it's worse than that it's like
because it isn't
i know it's i know it's different people
all the time but they all have the same
views on absolutely everything it feels
like you're
arguing with the borg you know it feels
like just one one mind speaking through
many many voices yes well it is that
then that's the hallmark of an ideology
it is precisely that
and then i guess it's a matter of
it's certainly and it's a matter of
trying to understand the ideology ever
more deeply to see what it's actually
focused on
but i do i do read their books and i do
read their articles and i do try to
understand
i don't believe the people i'm talking
about return the favor they they always
use the phrase
educate yourself and what they mean by
that is read these select books
and digest them uncritically that's what
they mean by educate yourself
you know they don't mean read widely and
and tackle the various views and come to
a conclusion yourself
the last thing they want is critical
thought critical thought is the enemy
uh you know ironically it's the enemy of
critical theories no it's a hallmark of
white supremacy culture as far as i can
see
right that's what they say well that's
because it's amazing too to see that
set of ideas propagate itself across the
culture so quickly
the the canadian federal government in
its diversity inclusivity and equity
training program
now uses those concepts like associating
white supremacy with punctuality for
example
they use those in the training of their
civil servants it's it's
been accepted wholeheartedly to that
degree
i've seen them i've seen the screenshots
that often get leaked of these training
sessions
bullet pointed uh hallmarks of white
supremacy punctuality politeness
hard perfectionism yeah all these noble
things
and i'm thinking well if i was a person
of color i would be outraged
by this this idea that this is this is a
culture that's alien to me this is
it's so offensive uh and this is what
it's so absurd even i mean it's so
observed that you you can hardly mount
an argument against it i mean
conscientiousness is is a is a
personality trait and
there's no racial differences in
conscientiousness
right and it it wouldn't matter to me if
it was just a few idiots on twitter or
these extreme it wouldn't matter to me
but
these people have disproportionate power
institutional power political power
i mean the biden administration is is on
on side with an awful lot of this kind
of of stuff and
and the end so is the trudeau government
i mean to have this in the
in the training uh training
documentation that's produced by the
federal government it's just absolutely
stunning it's also the document
that i was referring to i tweeted about
it yesterday it's so badly written that
it's
it's it's it's stunning it's maddening
with him
we don't know and how is it he's got
away with his history of blackface for
instance how is it that
there is no consistency there like you
know
lack of effective opposition is a big
part of it it's insane i mean if you
look at those old videos it looks like
he spent more time in blackface than out
of it and yet
he he isn't the one who's being attacked
and vilified for that it's okay he's got
a free pass it's weird to me
yeah well the the opposition in canada
and this is a problem in general is
a real problem for our entire culture is
that the woke narrative is very
romantically attractive
it's got this rebelliousness about it
and this
impetus to go out and march in the
streets and you know to work on a global
cause and
like traditional conservatives and even
traditional liberals
can't mount a counter narrative they
they don't have the
imagination and it's a huge problem
the trouble is though the cause that
they're fighting for is large largely
illusory
and that that to me is is is very
frightening we've had people in this
country
claim that our major universities such
as oxford and cambridge are
structurally institutionally racist all
of the data tells us this is
just simply not the case oh yes well
that's just happening constantly in
canadian universities the
mcgill physics department has now put
out a diversity inclusivity and equity
statement and that that's predicated on
exactly those views
well i think we need to push back
against the this particular
hyper racialization of society because
it is reinscribing old racial tropes
even to the extent of fear of
miscegenation this old racist idea of
this fear of mixed couples you know
there was an article
in the garden here recently talking
about how finding mixed race people
attractive is problematic you know this
idea it's almost just
taking old racist ideas and just giving
them a kind of hint of respectability
and of course the end point of that
is segregation you saw presumably the
story at the in
in california the brentwood school the
elite school that segregated its parents
but
on their their what was it a dialogue
session with the teachers and
you would have white parents in one
you're seeing that in convocation
ceremonies at universities too
how can this not how can this be
anything other than racist you know
it's interesting that the the group fair
you know the the group um foundation
against intolerance and racism
a lot of those those people who are
doing great work i think are starting to
call this neo-racism there needs to be a
label
for it um and i think maybe that's the
right way to go about it because
the word racism has almost become
meaningless because the the people who
use it the most they throw it around
so liberally you know that that i never
believe it when i hear someone branded
that way i assume
it's someone not being honest and not
being truthful so what do we call this
what do you call it when
people are advancing the cause of racial
segregation in the name of anti-racism
what do you call that i don't know what
i think i think that's going to be the
real struggle it's not it's not just
breaking through the fantasy world i
don't like this idea of having to
negotiate someone else's dreamland
there's that thing firstly but also
there's the linguistic minefields
how do you convince people the other
reason i mean you mentioned the
rebellious aspect of it
i think the other reason why it's so
appealing is because the language
sounds like you're doing good social
justice
anti-racism who wouldn't be anti-racist
black lives matter of course they do who
would disagree with that
but but but these that these phrasing
can be used to push through some very
pernicious
uh ideas and i mean when it comes to
anti-racism
for instance i mean ibrahimovic candy
makes absolutely clear in his book
that he feels to be not racist is simply
another form of racism
that this that this dichotomy doesn't
exist well
what and that's why i find it very hard
when i'm having these arguments because
if i say
i have a real problem with anti-racism
people will say oh i see so you're for
racism
and then you have to explain what
anti-racism means when used by these
academics in these very niche
fields such as whiteness studies you
have to explain first what that means
why that's dangerous for society and how
in order to
genuinely oppose racism you have to
oppose the discourse of anti-racism i
mean when you say it like that it's it's
it's maddening isn't it it's it's like
it it it it's it's it's the stuff of
nightmares
because there is no coherent sense and
and because so much of it is rooted in
language and
misdirection through language and and
and shielding what is actually meant
it it becomes impossible to win the
argument and
and maybe that's the point you know
maybe maybe this
they gave the word to us gaslighting you
know when they when they gaslight all
the time and say the culture war is a
right-wing myth
or cancel the people who are the the
chief practitioners of cancer culture
saying that council culture doesn't
exist when they
when they say the opposite of what what
is the observable reality
i i don't know how to uh break
through that how to how to break through
those arguments because not only
have they constructed a pseudo-reality
in their own minds they've constructed
the language
with which to sustain that
pseudo-reality so no one else can be
drawn out of it
and that that to me is going to be the
challenge
let me ask you let's go sideways for a
minute now
and and i suppose this is an exploration
of potential solutions as well
this has been a very serious
conversation but you're a satirist and a
comedian as well
and so terrible how unfunny i am
in real life isn't that awful you know
it's when i'm doing stand-up if i've got
a script i can be funny but i can't
be funny spontaneously people are very
disappointed about that i'm sorry
well i'm i'm curious about your
motivations
let's talk about titanium mcgrath why
don't you define
describe her first for everyone so tony
mcgrath
originated as a twitter character um in
around april 2018 and the idea of the
character is that she is a very
um privileged po-faced uh young
white intersectional activist who is
determined to be offended by absolutely
anything she can problematize absolutely
anything you know you could give her
you know a pair of shoes or a hat or a a
holiday in my gate
and she would find a way to say that it
is a irredeemably
transphobic and white supremacist or
something like that she can do those
things that the activists always do so
nothing is ever good enough for her
she's also immensely privileged she
comes from well independently wealthy
background
she lives in you know one of those uh
sort of gated communities which is
99 white um but she uh she she has a
deep mistrust of the working class
um and um she but she she
thinks that she is virtuous and noble
and good and she goes on twitter
uh and uh goes on the attack all the
time
uh trying to uh isolate things trying to
save the world with in her
through through uh intersectional theory
um and it's a very recognizable type of
act even if you know nothing about
intersectional
intersectionality or anything of the
stuff that came out of the the school of
thought of kimberly crenshaw or any of
those academics even if you know nothing
about that
you will recognize this type of figure
because this figure is ubiquitous
on twitter on social media they always
have their pronouns in their bio
they always use the same terminology
such as hegemony or discourse or
or problematic or phallogocentric if you
want to go back to deredar you know
and she knows the right jargon to use
lived experience cultural appropriation
mansplaining toxic masculinity all of
those kind of things
and we know and all of these things tend
to be slogans in substitute of thought
you know they they're just things that
get thrown out there and and so what i
wanted to do with the characters you
know what slogan means
what you mean is uh etymologically no i
don't slough garam it means battle cry
of the dead
i love that oh god for sure
i mean that doesn't send a chill up your
back you didn't understand it
well that's this is it that i'm gonna
use that that's great because that
it is a kind of uh it's almost like a
battleground of zombies who who don't
have any capacity for independent
thought anymore i mean you you try to
get into a conversation with with
someone like this and
i have slept many times very publicly
and the slogans that come back at you
all the time and
and and the lack of interrogation of
those slogans you know but what i find
so frustrating and so horrifying in some
sense i mean
i think a great canonical example of
that is the interview that helen lewis
did with me for the
for gq which is it's now more popular
online than the channel 4
interview which i think the gq interview
has like 32 million views or something
preposterous but i never did talk to
helen lewis
i just talked to the ideology and it
it's not
i don't like that i like to talk to the
person and find out what they think
but i heard you saying as well that
before the interview
uh she was very uh frosty and and
and oh yes almost as though she had
decided what you were in advance finally
oh there was no almost
right yeah she definitely decided what i
was before the
before the discussion yes exactly and
she's been beating the same drum more
recently as well
which has driven many people to the
interview because she published an
article in the atlantic monthly and in
another locale as well
um so when when you're faced with those
i mean it
i just see it all the time so often and
to give another recent
example that we had the um obviously
since the harry and
megan interview with oprah winfrey uh
and there was a controversy over here
because piers morgan who hosts a show
called good morning britain
got into an argument with another
colleague on the show man called alex
beresford i think
and um it was really interesting
watching once they had the argument they
sat down they tried to talk through the
issues
and piers morgan pointed out that some
of the things that megan had said in the
interview
were factually wrong and had been proven
to be factually wrong
his response was alex berefort's
response was but that's her lived
experience and then he said
yes but we have the evidence here that
it is factually incorrect and again he
said
but it's her lived experience so in
other words she that's that insistence
that the fantasy world
the subjective world trumps everything
right
so so and that once you've it's almost
like these
these phrases if you use the right if
you use the phrase lived experience or
toxic masculinity whatever
you're in the club what you've signaled
that you're you're you're right
you know and i know that academics have
always done this you know the jargon
you're you're in the group you're in the
in group if you've got the right if you
know how to deploy the right words
but there's something more sinister
about this because it is morally right
in these situations
that that's the sinister thing
it's morally incontrovertible you've
made the statement and that's it and
there's no further discussion that's
right you're not evil
that's what you're saying right i'm not
evil so i think so with
so the reason with titania i wanted her
to be obsessed with this language and so
and
and and why i read so much of this stuff
so that i knew the way that they speak
is because i thought the best way to
expose the the inherent contradictions
of of
of that position and the thoughtlessness
moreover the thoughtlessness of that
position
is is is to to embody it in a character
right so you were playing you were
playing a dramatic game essentially
which is a form of thought in doing so
i've actually uh
come to understand the people i'm
satirizing a whole lot more
and look let's face it every now and
then they'll hit on a point that is
actually
right and and you know even when i read
white fragility by robin deangelo which
i think is a terrible book and is
is so flawed throughout every now and
then she'll hit on something and you
think for a moment oh
there's something in that and then
she'll undercut it by saying well
everyone's a racist and all the rest
you know and it just goes back to being
absurd but um
and that book and of itself is a very
good example of this you know setting up
a reality that cannot be
penetrated because she will say that any
kind of uh
critical questioning of her position is
evidence
of the very pervasiveness of white
supremacy that she's identified so you
can't win
because even engaging in a discussion is
proof of your malevolence according to
her theory it's absolutely hopeless
um but i thought i thought i thought
because the movement is so written with
contradiction
actually the more effective way of
tackling it isn't through dialogue
firstly because
the people i'm talking about seem are
impervious to reason
uh they mistrust dialogue they see
debate as a form of violence so you're
never going to get through to them that
way
yeah and that that's actually an
explicit part of the theory
it really is so then in creating a
satirical character right it's not that
they're anti-free speech there's no such
thing as free speech in that theoretical
framework
it's a misapprehension all the way down
to the bottom which is why i
get so frustrated i've often been in
debates where i've tried to invite
these very people to participate in the
debate to hear them out
and they would say that to even appear
would be to dignify
the position so it's an absolute
nightmare
um and it also protects themselves from
from potential criticism which is of
course
the whole point but i but i thought by
creating a satirical character that
embodies
those contradictions that
thoughtlessness it might reflect back
onto them i suppose how they look to
normal people
because i don't think they appreciate i
think they're so caught up within their
own little bubbles
within their own little groups they they
never hear an alternative point of view
i mean i
i used to work with academics like this
who were so within their little groups
and they're constantly quoting each
other and supporting each other and
giving the illusion that their views
uh cannot be disputed uh but if you're
but what if you you're suddenly
confronted with how other people
perceive you and will that give you
pause for thought okay so
when you started to tanya you didn't
announce that she was a satirical
character you started playing on twitter
tell me
tell me the story exact what exactly
what happened because
sh that twitter account became
extraordinarily well known and very
rapidly so i'm curious about
what how you did that and how you
responded once it started to
you know amass some cultural
significance
i was very surprised that it took on um
it became so popular so quickly and
i'd started it uh because more to
entertain myself more than anything i
was so frustrated with this and i wanted
to
try and expose the absurdity of i mean
my background is a stand-up comic
and as a stand-up comic i'm not
necessarily satirical i will stand there
on a stage and
ridicule the thing that i perceive to be
a problem with society with satire
what you're doing is you're often
embodying it with a kind of ironic
detachment or you are
you know you're addressing it you're
always going after what you perceive to
be the vices and follies of society and
i thought that was a good
way of doing it right so you had to stay
on a kind of edge you had to be
believable enough as the character right
so that you could pass
but you had to push it just past the
point of of
of what of rationality or believability
it's a funny edge
i i was continually getting into
arguments with people and staying in
character i've always stayed in
character
uh even to today and i've actually if
you go to the titanic account now my
pinned thread
is a thread of conversations that i've
had with people in character
who are angry about the things i've
tweeted and these can go on for pages
and pages and it's fascinating to me
because
um it's close enough to the truth she
says really ridiculous things really
absurd things like
um like is speaking or writing in
english as an act of colonial violence
she'll say that you know the only way to
guard against uh
fascism is if the state are allowed to
arrest people for what they say and
think you know stuff like this which is
so obviously absurd
and yet it's close enough to what people
actually say
um that people believe it and get
annoyed about it and what i've always
liked to do is to stay in character and
have those conversations
with these people um and um
and then i posted the screenshots of the
conversation so but part of the point of
that
is not to humiliate the people who had
fallen for it because actually the point
i'm making is i understand why they
would fall for it because it's so close
to what people actually say um and
and and by doing that my hope is i
suppose
that it it exposes uh the folly of this
stuff sometimes even when i'm in those
arguments
i will say something that is so out of
the
out of you know just completely out of
the realm of possibility so stupid
um and yet they still don't things have
become so absurd
that they don't twig i mean even today
there was a story today in the uk
uh a museum a jane austen museum is now
going to interrogate
jane austen's use of sugar in her tea
because it has connections to
plantations and white supremacy and
slavery
you know something like that which is
just so absurd all the
the recent controversy of a bluey the
australian
cartoon dog because it doesn't have
enough dogs of color
and and gender diverse dogs in the
cartoon
now that sounds like something i would
make up as a joke
um but it's real it's it's actually
happening and people are taking it
seriously
and so therefore in a sense it's become
harder with titania
because anything that i come up with uh
is going to be topped
by by real life very very quickly um
what have you learned about the people
that titania annoys so she's a
hyper politically correct avatar and but
she tangles up people who are opposed to
that sort of thing and so that must have
also shed substantial light
for you on people on the other side of
the it does
and so what have you learned well one of
the things is that the people on the
other side
who might even be quite um might even be
of my opinion about these things
uh a lot of people are very quick to
anger and
and verbal abuse as a as a goat
as an instant response um so a lot of
the people who get angry with her really
go
after her looks and and i mean she's not
real um a friend of mine lisa created
the image of the woman she's a composite
of four different
women so it's not a parodies it is a
thing it's not a parody of any
particular person it's a
it's a type of of person um and
yeah the the the people who get angry
with her the people who are genuinely
angry about the social justice movement
are absolutely furious about the way it
is impinging on
every aspect of their lives they are
sick of it so when they see someone as
extreme as to tania they really let rip
and i don't think that's healthy you
know i it's not in my nature to go and
abuse someone online or to get angry
online
it's but i've seen the extent what it
what it shows i suppose
is that that kind of uh uh instinct
to immediately go for the abusive or the
vicious or the attack
or the ad hominem is present across the
political spectrum it's uh it's
it's it's everywhere or maybe that's
just a sign of twitter
maybe that's just a symptom of of social
media
um and i've learned a lot about how
social media works i think that's
that's another thing about it is that
i've really uh for one thing
the the fact that she's she's been
banned a number of times and i've
learned how to avoid the bands and
about about the way that big tech
sensors and how they censor and why
what is she being banned for so
uh the tweets that she was banned for a
couple of times she's had a
number of one day suspensions a number
of seven day suspensions
once or twice it's been inexplicable to
me why why
she would be banned it seems a bit like
someone at silicon valley has twigged
that their precious ideology is being
mocked and they don't like it that
that's the only explanation i can think
of
however on a couple of instances it's
when she's uh
i suppose what they would say incited
violence um and of course she hasn't
done anything of the kind there was one
tweet where she said she was gonna go to
a uh
a ukip rally ukip is a right-wing
nationalist political party in the uk
and she said i'm going to go to this
ukip rally to punch people in the name
of
compassion or love or something like
that you know which is the idea that a
lot of
these activists have that actually
whereas words are violence and awful
actual physical violence can be defended
uh you know in
their view it's so perverse and of
course i was making a comment about
the perversity of that idea that that
you think microaggressions are
are actual violence but you're perfectly
content uh to go out and set fire to
cars and beat people up if they have the
wrong opinion or pepper spray people in
the face if they voted for trump you
know there's an obvious
there's an obvious contradiction there
that i was trying to expose so she had a
ban there
i think that might have even been the
one where she was permanently banned i
had an email from twitter saying
this is a permanent ban you're not
getting back on and then there was a bit
of an outcry
from from uh from people who follow some
prominent people who follow her
and twitter rescinded that changed their
minds and and brought her back and as a
result of that inevitably
her follower account left because of
course when you try and censor something
you draw attention to it
but you're always treading a fine line i
mean my friend lisa who i mentioned lisa
graves used to have a
twitter account called jarvis dupont who
was one of my favorite accounts on on
twitter
and he was um banned completely
permanently banned they actually went on
a bit of a
purge of satire accounts there was one
afternoon where twitter purged
12 or 13 satirical accounts and deleted
them
titania came back for some reason i
think it's because she was the bigger
account
but a lot of them just got ditched and
that i think shows that
you know the the powers that be at
silicon valley they don't like to be
mocked they don't
well no one in authority likes to be
mocked it's the best way to undermine
authority isn't it and it's
it's why every despot in history has
killed the clown well that's why we have
to be so careful when any of our laws
start making comedians nervous they're
the ultimate canary in the coal mine
even more so than artists i think the
artists are next probably but
absolutely i mean you all know in canada
mike ward was fined
i think forty two thousand dollars uh by
the quebec human rights commission for a
joke that he told if
and by the way if you you know this yes
montreal of course has one of the
world's great comedy festivals and
and some of that humor i've been to the
comedy festival a couple of times and at
midnight you can go and hear
particularly outrageous comedy which i
actually think it was in one of those
where he said what he got fined for
and i you know i don't even know the
context because because he said it in
french for one thing so i didn't fully
understand but i read the transcript and
i spoke to him about it and
what was interesting is that he's not
some you know open mic
act who's who hasn't been on the he's an
established
famous successful uh comedian who was uh
who was fined for a joke that if you
actually break it down and analyze it
there's nothing remotely offensive about
it you know i mean it's perfectly pop
there i don't think comedy can it can
exist without the potential to cause
offence
neither can truth right quite comedy
is almost always truth almost always
that comedian says something funny and
it's true in a way that people didn't
expect and they know it
and and well it's also that it's also
that thing of of of uh
of teasing the boundaries of tolerance
of of of almost
almost having that kind of cathartic
effect the way that the the ancient
greeks would watch
a tragedy and and hear about this
dismemberment and all sorts of
i think to philosophically to purge
themselves of the
of of that evil that lay within uh in a
sense when you hear a comedian
say something utterly outrageous uh it
it can have that effect on you and you
laugh in spite of yourself and then you
laugh again
because you are saying to yourself why
did i laugh at that that makes me i
shouldn't have done that so you're
almost laughing at your own response as
well it has a double effect
and we are really losing that i mean i
don't know how it is
in canada but but but in the uk a lot of
this kind of
mistrust of comedy and mistrust of jokes
and the idea that certain jokes
normalize hatred is coming from the
comedians themselves and a lot of
comedians
uh take it on themselves to police other
comedians material
and they get very angry when people
broach certain
subjects i've i consider it very very
unhealthy um and not all comedians by
the way i'm not saying that all
comedians i'm just saying
certainly the more establishment
comedians absolutely uh
would fall into this category and it's
it's really shocked me this has been
since i started tatania in particular a
lot of comedians have been very angry
that i mocked the social justice
movement or you know that i
you know which to me is absurd because
you know i spent years three years
writing
co-writing the jonathan pie character
and because that predominantly
mocked trump and the right and
conservatives
and and you know it went those were the
targets that was okay
so i never got uh this kind of venom
about about that
but as soon as i was mocking social
justice ideology which i perceive to be
an extremely powerful ideology you know
this isn't
i don't think i'm punching down i think
i'm punching up at these at these
these people who have captured these
institutions and and are ruthless by the
way absolutely ruthless and bullying
i think the social justice movement
utterly legitimizes bullying and i don't
like bullies and i like to stand up to
bullies and that
titania is my attempt to stand up
against the bullies but what they will
do
is misrepresent my intentions and will
say oh no you just want to have a go at
gay people or whatever or have a go at
minority groups and and
i've been very shocked by that because
that that kind of response has even come
from comedians
and my viewers that if you've got half a
brain you know that's not what i'm doing
you i mean you absolutely have to know
that that's what not what i'm doing and
yet
maybe they do know maybe that maybe this
is a willful misinterpretation as a
means to attack me
because i've because i've mocked the
ideology i'm not meant to mock but i
tell you what whenever there's
whenever there are consequences for
mocking someone then i think that's the
person you ought to be mocking right
i think that's a sign
do you would you what effect has
producing titania had on your life and
and if you could go back and decide
whether you were going to do it
again would you i mean it must be
shocking
i would think it's shocking to have have
seen what happened
to be at the center of what happened
when you created that character
but i'd like to know i well for one
thing i didn't
yeah i didn't expect the reaction that i
got also you've got to remember that for
a long time the character i was
anonymous
um because i i part of the effects of
the character was that people thought
she was real that was so
sort of integral to it and then i was
outed by a newspaper over here
the week that her first book came out
um and that although that was very good
for the book because it generated a lot
of publicity because then the story
became that i was the person behind the
character
um in effect it had an innovating impact
on the on the
on the character because now what
happens people know it's me behind the
character people
however what i will say is even to this
day there's always some people who fall
for it whenever i tweet something
there's always some people who fall for
it so it has that
so so there's that but then there's the
impact on my personal life well
i would do it again because i feel
very passionately uh that the the
movement that i'm mocking the ideology
that mocking is a dangerous one
and i i feel very passionately that it
is uh
uh divisive and damaging to society as
damaging as any ideology can be i think
it has the potential to go to those
lengths um
and and so that i think i would almost
be in dereliction if i
if i didn't mock it it would be it would
be i tell you what it would be it would
be an act of self-censorship
if i didn't go after these targets and
that's by the way how most comedians i
mean a lot of comedians think this stuff
is ridiculous they won't go near it
because they know that if they do they
won't get on the bbc
and they won't get booked by certain
clubs so they just leave it well alone
but i think
i i i couldn't do i could i i just
that's not
in my nature so i so i don't regret that
the fact that so many friends of mine
former friends on the company circuit no
longer talk to me that's something which
i suppose i could
say is unfortunate on the other hand
how many times has that happened to you
how many friends do you think you've
lost
it's in double figures it's certainly in
double figures and i think
um and it's not just titania it's also
partly i suppose my politics it's also
um
it's it's effectively being honest about
what i think uh and saying opinions that
might not be the establishment of
fashionable opinions and it gets people
very angry i mean one
particular incident i could think of was
when i met for a drink with two friends
very old friends of mine a married
couple and uh he started
screaming at me in the pub call i won't
swear on your podcast but calling me
an effing nazi and then another word
which i probably shouldn't say at this
point
um but but and and i thought he was
joking at first and and we had this
conversation
and it was true he'd he'd completely
bought into this fantasy of who i was
and and there was no going back from
that
um and i know it was fueled by alcohol
but no apology was forthcoming or no no
you know it's and then every now and
then there'll be i mean it happened to
be a couple of months ago where a
comedian i've known for many many years
from the circuit
suddenly sent me this abusive message
online on twitter
and started attacking me and saying i
was he said i was
funded by dark foreign powers or so or
something
utterly absurd you know and um
and i thought well okay so this is now
that is what you'd say if you were
funded by dark foreign powers
well this is this is the problem like i
said i said you know i've said it before
if uh
you know if i am getting all this dark
money it must be very dark because i
haven't seen any of it it's not
you know that'd be great fine but i'm
not and this idea that i'm this sort of
it's that going right back to what you
said at the start like that i'm
defending free speech
because i i because i'm an evil person
who wants to say evil things and
so there's all of that all that i'm
mocking
i'm mocking minority groups through to
tania which is absolutely not what i'm
doing it's the opposite i'm
i'm mocking those very affluent and
powerful people
who uh very patronizingly assume that
they
they know what's best for minorities you
know it's the opposite of what
people say it is um but these kind of
experiences
uh on the one hand i think it's a bit
sad isn't it because
there are people now i've had to go
through my phone and delete
lots of numbers because i know we'll
never talk again but on the other hand
were they my friends to begin with i'm
not so sure you know if they can
if they can suddenly become so bigoted
and that is the word
well it's an indication of how profound
the divide has started to become in our
culture right that
i mean 20 years ago i never lost any
friends because of my
hypothetical political opinions but um
changed you must have lost your case
must be much more severe than mine
you know because you're so much more
famous and so much more known has
have lots of friends turned on you no
actually
not not a lot some there's some
outstanding exceptions
although even in those situations i
would say there was extenuating
circumstances no i've been
i've been really fortunate in that
regard that my
my close circle of of intimates my
family and and my
my close friends have been staggeringly
loyal to me
under which is wonderful severe distress
yes that's wonderful
so is it maybe the case does that tell
us that actually
what it's really about is the fact that
i was working in an industry
which is you know the so the comedy
industry
is so on board with the woke ideology to
such an extent that in fact
so many of it's it's uh so many
comedians are now really
just uh advertised for that for that
ideology maybe
maybe i mean my professional colleagues
certainly haven't leapt to my defense
well that's that's what i was going to
ask actually surely
no that's been no that's pretty much
done with i mean i
i would say my name i've decided this
recently
because of the slurs that have been
associated with me
i can't in good conscience accept
graduate students anymore because right
if they go out
you know you talked at the beginning
about this register where
that's been set up in britain where if
you
are charged accused of a non-crime hate
act yeah it's recorded without a trial
i mean i've been on hiring committees
many many times and
especially in academia there's an
oversupply of highly qualified people
of radical oversupply and so if there's
anything in your record at all that's
the least bit
uh contentious it's like you're you're
done
and so being my student that's not a
little bit contentious that's
really really contentious and so it's
now become impossible for me to
to uh to serve my proper function as a
as a scientist and as a university
professor so that's
it's taking a lot of adjustment on my
part to get accustomed to that
and i don't practice clinically anymore
as well and there are a variety of
reasons for that but
certainly the
i've become very very susceptible to
attacks through the college of
psychologists
the governing board they can make the
life of a practitioner
brutally miserable with a single letter
and that's
very very punishing and it's also
perhaps not
necessarily good for my potential
clients to be associated with someone
who's
controversial they already have enough
trouble so
although i've been fortunate on the
family and friends front the
on the professional front things have
have been
you know more dismal isn't that just
suggestive of the of the the power of
this movement and and
the effectiveness of the effectiveness
of cancer culture in fact
the way the ease with which people can
become stigmatized
you know all it takes is a few
accusations of your far-right or
alt-right or whatever and
it's there you know any prospective
employer can google that and it comes up
and who's going to take the risk
you know the accusation is sufficient to
damn you
and and that's that's what
you put the finger on the on the
absolute catastrophe of the
non-crime hate index it's like well
it's it's a permanent stain especially
in a
in a technological universe where
nothing is ever forgotten
no matter how long the lag and it's
worse because the government here feels
no compunction to address this or or to
no politicians seem to has well i
suppose
they are well because the strategy is
that if you oppose
hate speech laws you're obviously a
hateful person why else would you oppose
hate speech
you know it's the old thing and a
politician doesn't want to stand up in
parliament to be the one
who is seen to be siding with the the
evil guys the bad guys well you have to
make a very very subtle argument to
stand up against hate speech laws
because you're faced with the problem
that there is such a thing as hate
speech
yeah obviously so when it's pernicious
and terrible it's like
okay so you're arguing uphill
this is again why it's such a bloody
miracle that we ever had free speech to
begin with it's
almost inconceivable to me that we
managed to generate
the baseline presumption of innocence
that's a miracle
the the fact that you can go bankrupt
and start again
that's a miracle the idea that you ever
had free speech and that that was
genuinely the case that's a miracle and
none of this is
is given the appropriate respect and awe
that it deserves
because it's so unlikely it's hugely
unlikely i mean
i know in the book i i talk a give a
kind of very very short
history of a free speech from the
ancient greeks to today and it and it
the point of that is to accentuate this
point that actually the fact that we
have it
is astonishing and unlikely so unlikely
and and all the more reason why we need
to defend it we need to be really really
vigilant about any
cracks that appear in this in this
because
it will go away very very easily you
know if we don't defend it
and it's hard particularly when it comes
to the idea of that's why i wrote a
chapter on hate speech because
and and and took the op the other side's
view seriously
because just trashing the opposing
argument isn't going to help we have to
talk about it and explain
you know why it's important nevertheless
well for one thing like you say
hateful speech exists let's start from
that point
let's acknowledge that that hateful
speech exists and it can be hurtful and
it can do damage
but then the alternative is a state that
might
in the future be completely unscrupulous
that is going to decide for you what
what you can say and those are the
things that we have to tackle and no
but and the other key thing is that no
one knows how to define hate speech you
know
unesco the european court of human
rights they they've all agreed
there's no way to define hate speech
every european country that has hate
speech laws
has different hate speech laws different
definitions subjective
abstract concepts such as hate such as
offense
such as a perception you know and these
are on the statute books and you don't
want this stuff on the statute books
because it's all very well i mean i know
the we talked about the smp and their
hate crime bill
the defense i'm always running into is
people are saying yes okay
technically someone could be arrested
and imprisoned for saying some
an offensive joke technically yes but no
one in their right mind no jury
no judge uh is going to
we've got common sense it's okay well
that's so myopic
i mean what because you don't know who's
going to be in charge in 10 years time
you don't know who that judge is going
to be you how can you possibly just you
can be
certain that someone will be in charge
that doesn't approve of you
and that you don't approve of that will
in right that will in
certainly happen you don't want vague
vague wording on the statute books
it's going to be exploited at some point
even though even if it's not today
there's absolutely no way that you can
guarantee it against future
against the future abuses of that and i
don't
it is as you say it's a certainty so i
i'm i'm
yeah i think it's i think it's actually
one of the most important arguments that
we should make
uh and that and that we need to do you
know free speech needs to be defended in
every successive generation it's not
something that
you you know you know this you get it
and then it's there forever no that's
not true
but there's something about human nature
there's something about people in power
there's something about the way that
we are uh that
it will collapse it's an edifice that is
not secure
at any given time and but it's hard it's
that thing of
of being smeared the risk is you're
going to be smeared you're going to be
associated with the worst possible kinds
of people because of course
it's only really controversial speech
that ever requires protection uh
and people are going to say well then
you must support what what these awful
people are saying and
it's it's hard to make the case but it's
a case that nonetheless has to be made
and particularly by politicians i've
been incredibly disappointed
uh by the way in which uh politicians in
this country have not
made any kind of effort to to if
anything as from what i can see
uh there are moves even in the in the
english parliament to push through
further hate speech laws we should be
repealing them not pushing for them but
but no one wants to have the argument no
one wants to be tainted
yeah well they get identified one by one
and taken out that's what happens
well you get put on a list this is it
the the the the identitarian left if
that's what we're going to call them
i don't know what to call them that's
the problem is they're very clever about
evading even a label
um but they like making their lists they
like observing and saying you know you
you you are you are problematic uh you
have sinned
and and and now they have a an
electronic trail
they they these are the people that
absolutely love going through all of
your old tweets and messages
and anything they can find uh and of
course the point about that is you can
do that to anyone there is no one
alive who if you had complete unfettered
access to everything they've ever
written online or in
their emails or text messages that you
couldn't construct a case to damn
someone
that's actually one of the things that's
more or less saved me
is right well by the time i made my
political statement which was a
philosophical statement or even a
spiritual statement not a
political statement i already had 200
hours of lectures online and
so essentially everything i'd ever said
to students was recorded
and there wasn't it wasn't possible to
pull out a smoking pistol
so this was very smart and also i mean
but this is why it's also astonishing
i i find it unendingly astonishing the
way you are mischaracterized because
because it's all there everything you
think is out in the open you've been
very very
very clear and explicit about your point
of view and so
when they try and demonize you and turn
you into this thing people can check and
they'll realize that you're
i think what they're doing is they're
relying on the reputational damage
being a kind of barrier to people even
investigating who you really are
yeah well to some degree that that works
but it it doesn't really work because
what
genuinely generally happens is that you
know for every person who
wouldn't open a lecture because of my
reputation
there's three or four who do because
they're curious and
and then it has an even more perverse
effect on
in some cases on the true believers
because they're
primed to find anything i said offensive
but
that doesn't happen or maybe they even
find it useful and then
that's not good at all it's like well
he's
interesting when you meet the people
when you get into conversation with
people and you and you can see
that you're not what they thought you
were and they don't know quite what to
do with that
you know and that that to me is that to
me is why another reason why we need
more speech not less we need to have
the conversation so that people can be
disabused of the fantasies that they've
been wallowing in
you know but i do very much enjoy that
when when uh
people expect one thing and then they
actually actually
speak to me and and they they don't see
that that there's no evidence of it
because it doesn't exist
yeah well it's interesting to watch that
unfold in the public domain too i
mentioned those two
interviews the channel 4 interview that
has
been viral and and the interview by by
helen lewis at gq and
those interviews basically consists of
consist of nothing
but
the attempt by the interlocutor to have
a conversation with the person that
exists in their imagination right
because there is almost no relationship
to me at all that was particularly the
case with
with uh kathy newman and
yeah i was less so with helen lewis but
it was still that was still essentially
the issue
it's quite reassuring though isn't it
that that once it's out there people can
see through it
you know it's very reassuring is and
what's what's saved me and this has
given me an endless supply of hope i
would say is that
all i've ever had to do is be is just
show everything it's like here's
the situation no edits like this is what
happened
and every time so far
so far you know i haven't
been fatally damaged um yeah
i mean one of the things one of the
things i've learned most i think since
since uh titania kicked off and and it
became a known thing is i've learned
simply never to trust uh the perception
of someone
as as as constructed in the media or
online or you know i i it's not it's
never the same person i've i've ended up
meeting
coming from the background i did most of
my friends were always on the left i
didn't really know
uh conservative people and now i have a
lot of friends who are conservatives
you know and they're just not this
villain that they were made out to be
and
even some famous conservatives who
people have said they're absolute
monsters they're evil they want to eat
babies basically the equivalent
you know and and you you get to know
them and you realize oh my goodness the
the the perception is so removed from
the so far removed from the reality
that even i once had had bought into it
myself because everyone's telling you
this
oh yeah the same thing is i've certainly
had that experience repeatedly
repeatedly
i never trust it now i like whenever i
hear the way people talk about people
online i just i
i never trust it unless i know someone
personally i'm never going to trust that
again
i think that's it's an important lesson
for me
so what's next for you and also how
how do you make a living you can't make
a living as titanium mcgrath oh well
i mean you're locked down still so it's
got to be hard being a comedian
right so i mean well comedy came to an
end i mean the last
i did a tour i did a stand-up comedy
tour in 2019
early 2019 and that was really uh
the last big thing i did because as soon
as i was about to do
some more live performances the lockdown
the lockdown came and
it's the same you know i'm not
complaining because absolutely every
live performer has has the identical
experience and we've
we've all you know i'm not in a position
to complain uh
and what yeah it's a very good question
i like it because it's also very direct
how do i make my money well
i um i write articles for various
publications i
um there's the the titania books
uh have have kept me going um i
obviously used to
work on the jonathan pie character we
had a couple of television shows and
live tours those those were particularly
lucrative and for a long time i did just
make my money as a stand-up comic so
literally just the money i would make
from um
from from the circuit uh now i've i've
just got a job with
well it's it's you know i gave up being
a full-time teacher for this
and i uh was
on a regular wage it was a good it was a
good salary and uh
i left it at great risk you know because
i don't come from a wealthy family i
don't have
the means to support myself without this
kind of stuff so
i uh i went well i actually went
part-time first and was
on the stand-up circuit and then i
started earning enough from the stand-up
to
to get by and so i went full-time stand
uh but i was i was really i was
genuinely struggling financially for a
long time
and then um then jonathan pie happened
which was very successful
uh particularly because we had a big
viral hit around the time of the donald
trump election
which actually went viral in america as
well and that really helped broaden the
character and then we did live tours and
all the rest of it we
we played the london palladium and the
hammers with apollo and so it was a big
thing
for me and then titania happened and the
book did very well and the second book
did well and
how many copies do you and you don't
have to tell me obviously but i don't
know
actually the truth is i don't know i i i
that's something i should ask
at some point it's the sort of thing i
don't look into you know it's i
i i i got a royalty check the other day
and i thought that
i thought it was done and actually this
was quite a lot of money i thought well
okay that so
that's good this is something that can
keep me going but i've also just got a
new job
um as a broadcaster on a new channel
called gb news
in the uk uh and that will be a pretty
full-time full-on
uh presenter job um so i will be
but what's good about that job is uh you
know i think we have a real problem in
them
with the news media in this country is
that we don't have enough diversity of
thought and
and the conversations that we ought to
be having this gives me an opportunity
to do that so it's very much related to
the work i've been doing
but in addition i'm going to continue
with my comedy work and
titania uh we're doing a uh some live
shows with titania
played by an actress we did that just
before the lockdown
we had to postpone the tour now we're
going to do another one um
so i will yeah it's it a lot of people
get very scared by
um making a living as a creative person
because you're always
like you it's a tough way to make a
living man
it really i mean you're taking a massive
risk and most
creatives i know are very very poor you
know it's it's simply not and most have
other jobs you know
there's a tiny fraction that are
hyper-rich and everyone else starves
virtually no one and i consider myself
extremely fortunate to be able to do
this full time the stuff i love
full-time because for most of my adult
career i couldn't
and i was you know i had to have a
full-time job and as well as go out in
the evenings
uh and do all of this stuff and and
so it's a real uh you have to really
commit
and and you also have to be aware in the
back of your mind of
the likelihood of failure that's it you
know that's the other thing that you
have to be fully aware of
um and i'm i'm by no means take it for
granted you know i i think
i'm here it's the stuff i've done comedy
and titania and the book i've just
written
none of this stuff would make me rich it
would it would it would keep me going
uh the new job i've got is going to be a
more regular income which is something i
miss i haven't had this
since i was a teacher i missed that you
know there was i missed routine and all
the rest of it
um yeah but i think another complicating
factor is not only
if you're trying to exist creatively not
only
is it a very high risk proposition
financially but
you lack that psychological
uh comfort that comes from routine which
you know people artistic people often
are
hyper critical of routine but god alive
man
routine keeps you sane and trying to
invent yourself every day that's
that's not for the faint-hearted i've
seen very few people manage that
successfully across decades
no absolutely and i i think particular
you know
particularly in comedy you know you
because you have to work for about three
or four years on the circuit
without getting paid anything in fact
you're losing money because you're
paying for your travel expenses and then
you get somewhere and you don't get you
don't get paid for it and and it's
this is why a lot you'll find a lot of
comedians particularly in the uk are
from
from quite wealthy backgrounds or
privately educated because
they you know they have rich parents who
can help them out put them up in a flat
and they don't have to work during the
day
and they escalate much quicker through
the ranks but
but if you come from my sort of
background you can't do that you have to
have the job
and then and you have to it's like
having two jobs
uh and so you have to really care about
it my advice is always i do believe
although it comes with that insecurity
if it is a vocation for you you have to
do i mean for me
i couldn't have done anything it is a
genuine vocation for me
even if i were making no money
whatsoever out of comedy or writing
or the rest i would still be doing it
because i would feel unfulfilled
if i were not doing it i think there's
something also quite i mean i take your
point about
the practicalities of living in the
business of living but my god i think
uh depriving yourself of your vocation
can be so soul-destroying
no it is well for for i've i've spent a
lot of time studying creativity
scientifically and
um the first thing that's useful to note
is that
creativity is not common i mean everyone
isn't creative
that's wrong some people are very
creative a minority of people are very
creative
and i mean it's it's a continuum but you
don't get
you know you don't get creativity till
you get out to the point where
what you're doing is original and that's
very difficult so it's a minority
proposition and then of those original
people there's only a tiny fraction that
can make a
successful financial go of it because
it's just you have to be creative plus
you have to have some sense for
marketing and sales and business and
you have to be reasonably emotionally
stable and etc etc it's
very very difficult but if you are
creative by temperament well that's you
and to not do that is to not be you it's
like asking an extroverted
person not to be around people or an
agreeable person
not to engage in intimate relationships
or a conscientious person not to be
driven by duty it's like
that's what you're like and so yeah
you're stuck with it it's a double-edged
sword creativity it's
vital it's entrancing it's necessary
um it's transformative it's disruptive
but it's a high risk high high risk
high return game and the probability of
failure is
overwhelmingly high even if you're an
entrepreneur
and you know more practically oriented
in your creativity the probability that
you'll make money from your innovation
or your invention
rather than other people is very very
low
but but you need to find a way i mean
it's also very difficult if you're a
creative person to
a lot of creative people don't think in
practical terms they don't think in
terms of uh
money actually they're hopeless a lot of
them might i know are hopeless in this
now they also tend to be casually
contemptuous of that to regard
as practical concerns as selling out
it's like you should be bloody happy if
you have the opportunity to sell out
so i think that the ideal is to find a
way to pursue your vocation but have one
eye
on the reality that you know you will
have to earn money somewhere and yeah i
mean yes
and i think it it's it's that's why i
think i'm lucky in so far as with
titania
i hit on something that had commercial
viability but it was very true to what i
desperately wanted to do
and i think that's so rare i think uh
some of the stuff i've written
some of the plays i've written for
instance i don't think would have any
commercial success
whatsoever but i wrote them because i
needed to write them and
and and some of them didn't even get on
and maybe one day they will and that
would be great but
well just think what you have to
accomplish though right you have to have
your creative endeavor aligned with
market demand at exactly that time
it's impossible yes it's very very
unlikely
actually that's why i always say don't
attempt to to
anticipate the zeitgeist because you
won't you like the best thing an artist
can do is do what they
believe and hope because a lot of it is
luck
i mean there's actually there's a
technical literature on that too i mean
what essentially what you do is continue
to produce ideas
and right it's a darwinian competition
essentially they're like life forms
these ideas
and now and then one will find a niche
that it can thrive in but but
the best way to uh maximize your chances
that that niche will manifest itself
is to be um is to over produce
because i look yeah for i'll give you an
example i answered a bunch of questions
on quora
so that's a website where anybody can
ask any questions and anybody can answer
i answered about 50 when i was playing
with quora
and one of them was a list of everything
people should know of things people
should know in their life and i derived
my books out of that list
yes it was disproportionately successful
most of the answers i generated got
virtually no views but it got
it must be hundreds of thousands now but
even before i wrote the books it was
tens of thousands
but had i not written 50 i wouldn't have
got that one
the other 49 failures so to speak were
the the answers weren't necessarily
worse they just didn't hit
the zeitgeist like that answer did and
and i think that's a great piece of
advice
over production because it's the same
with the beatles they they
they look like an overnight success it's
because they've been playing endlessly
in those
dingy clubs in in europe you know before
before it happens
it you you you produce they say it takes
ten years to become an overnight success
that's that's it so it you know of most
of the things i've written have done
nothing and gone nowhere and had no
success whatsoever it's just
but but the one thing occasionally when
it hits
that's that's what sustains all the rest
of it it's also why creativity
is is continues to be selected let's say
from a biological perspective it's like
that's why i said it was a high risk
high return game
almost everything you do creatively will
fail
but now and then you're
disproportionately successful
and so that keeps the whole game going
you didn't have any sense did you that
when you put the lectures on youtube
that it would explode in this way
i mean not in this way this was
completely i still
i i'm still shocked constantly
by my life i'm shocked out of out of
sanity by my life i just can't this is
why i asked you about titania you know
you
you get at the center of a whirlwind
like that and
there's something very surreal about it
and
i mean yeah i i keep getting hit by
surreal things and it's very hard to
wrap my head around it like this red
skull episode was just
one of many equally surreal occurrences
but
yes no i had no i had no
idea i knew i was working on something
important back when i was in my 20s when
i wrote my first book and
it was out of that that all my lectures
came and i spent 15 years working on
that book and i worked on it about three
hours a day
and so i re i and i thought about it all
the time
and so i knew there was something to it
not
necessarily because they were my ideas
but because of the people who i had read
and
and delved into while i was writing the
book i knew the ideas were
significant and and i could see the
effect of the ideas when i was lecturing
on my students so i had some sense that
there was something vital that i was
involved in something vital but sure but
had you uploaded those videos a couple
of years before or a couple of years
later you probably would have missed
the zeitgeist and nothing would have
happened you know i mean it doesn't
matter
i always think with any kind of creative
endeavor and or intellectually it
doesn't matter how
good you are in a sense it has to be
good and the timing has to be right and
and like you say if you just keep i
think persistence is it if you just keep
doing it not only
does your craft get better and and you
are when
if it does hit you're in a position
there's no doubt look if you if you
okay so in in scientific literature the
hallmark of
impact is citations and so if your work
is cited it means that someone
who's written another scientific article
makes reference to something you
wrote and that's all tracked and it's
used for promotions and
it's used to judge scientific merit it's
it's it's
it's its own science uh citation
tracking
um a very small number of
your published papers accrue most of the
citations so that's the first thing so
what that means is the more
papers you publish the more likely it is
that one of them will become highly
cited
and my highly cited papers aren't
necessarily the ones that i thought
would be
most impactful so yeah um you but
the other uh piece of information from
literature on creativity is that the
best
predictor of quality and so you could
index quality by impact let's say or by
citations
is quantity yeah it's not a great
predictor but it's the best one and so
and this is good advice for everyone out
there who's a musician or an artist it's
like
produce produce produce produce as much
as you can because you do get better at
it right
you absolutely do and and so there's
that but there's also
i think the other important thing is to
to actually be true to yourself
with in in your artistic endeavors in
safaris don't be trying to anticipate
the desire guys don't be trying to
anticipate what other people are doing
my big concern in the current climate
that we live in is that a lot of artists
are choosing to self
censor because the penalty for risk
taking has got
too high uh you know you can be
completely uh
i mean if i think about that think about
what kind of catastrophe that is because
we've already discussed the fact that
the impediments to creativity are almost
insurmountable
and so then you add an additional one
which is self-censorship because of
social pressure it's like
you just decimate the creative
enterprise by doing that we wouldn't
have anything we
we the western canada would be decimated
it's ridiculous i mean an example i
often think of
is one of my favorite playwrights is
edward albee and when he came to write
his play the goat which was a very
controversial play because it was about
a man
having an affair a sexual affair with a
goat behind his wife's back and
obviously that doesn't sound palatable
well at least he went beside behind his
wife's back
exactly at least it wasn't sort of an
open sort of paganistic thing absolutely
but um
i mean it's it's a shocking play and
it's meant to be it's about
where our lines of tolerance are where
they lie and why
um and all of his friends told him don't
do this you've got a
a valuable career an incredible
reputation you're turning 80 you're 80
he was roughly 80 years old when this
play came out
and they said you're just going to
scupper everything and he said that
one when that he got that response
that's the reason he did it he went out
there and he put the play on
and it turned out to be a huge success
it won i think the tony award for best
player was
critically and commercially successful
it was absolutely massive so
um it just goes to show i think uh to an
extent
i mean i'm not saying disregard uh
feedback from other creative people or
people who
who have suggestions what i'm saying is
if you're true to your muse
whatever that that is uh the rewards
will come actually or they are more
likely
okay so that brings us back to free
speech too because
you know the problem with laws that
abridge free speech is they abridge
creative endeavor and
that's a terrible thing because it's the
source of endless renewal
and it's the thing that fixes corrupt
structures and
so to to take aim at that is to take aim
at the very
process that would rescue you from the
conundrum you
you you are pretending to be obsessed by
i mean has there been any innovation not
just in artistic terms but in scientific
terms
without the risk of offense without you
know i mentioned i mentioned the example
of galileo in the in the book because
you know he wasn't he caused a great
deal of offense but
oh hell darwin who offended himself so
badly that
he was sick he was sick for like a
decade
because of the implications of what he'd
thought up which were
thoroughly offensive to himself as they
would be in
in with his belief system at the time
and and but
but that's that's the we can see in
hindsight
what we would have lost if people
weren't willing to risk offending
others in fact even what you said to
kathy newman in that interview about
you're risking being offensive by
disagreeing with me now in this way
like it's how it's important to risk
offending people
it's because otherwise you just end up
in this kind of
you know this hive mind and and and for
the arts
it becomes utterly stultified it becomes
so
boring when everything is predictable
and everything is in line with a
a viewpoint and no one wants to you know
the art is the best way that we
interrogate
the complexities of humanity it's it's
it's
i i love what sometimes what the
filmmaker lars von trier
he said in an interview once that
sometimes when he's making a film he
will take an indefensible moral position
and attempt to defend it through the
film which i think is such a fascinating
idea dostoevsky did that all the time in
his great novels and so brilliant i mean
that's what what made dostoevsky so
staggeringly
brilliant was he would take positions
that he
that he despised with all his soul and
make the people putting those beliefs
forward that strongest characters in the
book i mean he was
so brave it's the best thing to do it's
it's uh i wrote a play once where i i
complete i it was a one-man play
where i completely tried to embody the
kind of person i despise it was someone
who enjoyed
relished watching by acts of violence
and he would take uh
uh scour the internet for clips of real
life violence and it's something i could
you know whenever i've had that whenever
someone's tried to show me a beheading
or something i've
i know i never want to see that kind of
thing i know i never want that in my
head
and so i wanted to write a character who
who relished it
but from a position from a
non-judgmental position i've never put
that play on
i've written it it's done but but the
act of doing it was so
incredibly liberating and interesting um
and the idea that you can
you know you keep hearing this all the
time um you know
whenever a new film or a play comes out
of a book um is this sending the right
message david lynch's last series the
latest twin peaks series was criticized
i read a review saying
well there's violence against women in
this and he needs to be called out for
this
well representing violence against women
isn't an endorsement of violence against
women you know maybe that's what the
character does and maybe we're supposed
to hate him for it or whatever you know
and or if you read an autobiography of a
complete reprobate
there can be something really
interesting about that and and imagine
all of this gone
all of this potential but that is the
end point of of
that's why i believe that this this
current social justice ideology is
anti-art
i think it's it's it's opposed to the
the artistic spirit
quite quite fundamentally opposed to it
uh which is why i feel we must push back
against it so that's a great place to
end
no no that's great that's great well
thanks a lot e
uh much appreciated it was a pleasure
and
the time flew by which is a good marker
of a engaging
exchange of free speech let's say
absolutely thanks so much for having me
jordan my pleasure
good luck eh thank you
[Music]
you